I'll leak a little bit. I'll leak a little bit. Okay. Essentially,
I think Brianna Woo was like leading part of this thing that
was disjoint from the canvasing and she kept stepping on SEN's
toes and trying to dictate stuff for canvasing events and Sedra
was basically like, "Can you off you lazy?" Like, you don't do
anything. >> I can't I can't. She's the most unserious
person. Her resume says Gamergate. I'm pretty sure >> Kger.
Come on, man. I Come on, man.
That is widely expected to be her. Yes, that is widely expected
to be her doing a false flag like harassment of campaign against
herself. >> I heard she literally flew to Israel so she
could go into Gaza and drink the adrenochrome from the Palestinian
children like through the straw fresh. >> Yeah, I'm sure
that's true. >> I can't cooperate that. It's just a >> Sounds
accurate. Sounds accurate. So, there's two different Hassan dramas.
Okay. Both kind of involving bad and panata. Six days ago, Hassan
went on stream. He watched a bad empatada video that has a bunch
of info apparently on participants in Pave. That sucks. But I
to me I'm a little curious or concerned
about how shocked Hutch seemed to be that his info was out there.
Uh just from the PV stuff. Maybe he's not cuz I think I think
>> well Hutch seemed like really shocked about Hassan.
So to lead this off is the Hutch tweet from earlier today. right
now. He can he can be upset that Hassan's showing old info about
him, right? That includes his full name or something. I think
he can be upset about that if he wants to. That's that makes
sense. But just >> here, this is the tweet. This is like
the start of this. Okay. Hassan's Hassan claims he's banning
all mentions of Ban Impanata and purging Impanata's fan base.
Just another version of what the [__] I got mad about
people who love Mlestin like you're no different than DJ just
so you know. So apparently he says that [__] to ban
empanada fans. And Hutch quote tweets that tweet and says, "Here's
a son two days ago watching a banned put out a video on stream
that alleges I was paid through progressive victory pack to do
Zionist propaganda and make Destiny look good. Completely fabricated
claim based on nothing. He agreed with and expanded on these
claims to his audience." So this is what we're going to watch
as well. Um Pave collaborated with Destiny for canvasing events.
He was not part of the p that pack. Oh, maybe we'll just watch
the bad and banana stuff. Um he did not fund creators. I like
I don't think um I don't know. I can kind of clarify like some
of this stuff. Hut straw manning again. Well, hold on. I don't
think he's straw manning. I wouldn't doubt that Hassan says this,
right? They do tend to just make like big leaps, especially around
Israel. Um Taylor Loren does this too, which I it just annoys
me cuz it like they could be credible, but then they just make
these big leaps about all this other [__] Yeah. >> Okay.
I Okay, there's like this thing that
um PV offers
that I feel like people tried to sweep over when they say like
Destiny didn't get money from them. It was the idea that
canvasing is good for your like reputation.
You get you like legitimize yourself. It helps your reputation
or whatever. And if PV is able to completely fund it and a content
creator just has to support it, they are helping their reputation
by being part of it. Like the idea that just because a streamer
isn't getting money from a company or I mean from like a pack
doesn't mean that they're not benefiting from being part of that
system.
>> I yeah >> on his own some of his canvasing situation
was getting
um sabotaged.
So, in a way, this was a big help to him,
>> In a way, I think he gave way more help. From what I
remember, he gave way more help to Pave than they gave back.
Brianna Woo basically, >> you would think
by [__] recession. I'm sorry, but go ahead. >> Yeah.
Yeah. So, like there's a whole timeline with PV where Destiny
had his own canvasing operation and you you can fill in facts
here as as much as you want along the way. Maybe we could just
talk about all of this, but from what I I think you were involved
before I knew anything about it. Um, but from what I remember,
it was they went to Washington. You were there for that trip
and they were like talking or whatever. And then um after that,
>> I went to Washington on my on my own dime. Um >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. >> But I went there because I was interested
and
>> Yeah. But like with uh with Sedon and with that operation,
that operation worked pretty smoothly cuz Sedan actually knew
how to he was pretty good at logistics. He's pretty good at setting
everything up. >> He wasn't part of that >> with
Sorry, I'm saying when they actually go canvasing. >> Oh,
cuz Okay, so you're talking about when I went to Wisconsin. Sin
wasn't part of that at all. Son, when I met Sajun was when I
was in Georgia. >> I'm talking about Ohio and the just
the PV funding that was set up with the DG
>> Ohio was like a year after Wisconsin.
So, I had nothing to do with Ohio. >> I see. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I was just going to say that like basically I think what
they did was they made a house. They were trying to do like these
houses or whatever. They had a house for DG. Um they PV was supposed
to provide the money for it from what I recall. What they did
was they said, "Hey, Destiny, can you shill this link for us
for the house and basically it was like Destiny's audience funding
the PV branded
um everything." And I was kind of annoyed cuz I I was I was told
I hated Brianna Woo and Keeles. And so I was telling I was telling
Destiny like don't trust them as far as you can. I said one don't
actually trust Keeles at all. That person they're total they're
a total piece of [__] H little did I realize who
I was talking to. But for two, trust Brianna Woo as far as she'll
give you money. Literally trust nothing she says unless the money's
there. like unless you have money in your hands, do not trust
this person because they will like I don't I don't believe about
them. >> I do recall
uh like one or two streams of Aerodike going on and like telling
him to shill it to pin this in the Reddit looking for donations
and you can like see the disinterest in that exchange on stream.
Well, it's it's because like if he just wanted if he's going
to do all of the work and do all of the funding for PV, why the
would he like why didn't he just brand it DG? And I get that
some of it is like well actually you're like losing your but
>> you're losing like some of the
>> an idea, right, that it could get
PV was supposed to be like this umbrella thing that makes it
so that the
scandals of creators doesn't sabotage their um their like collective
or because they would all be under PV the collective effort in
helping politically or like galvanizing like the audience to
do stuff mobilizing them. So, it it really sucks when you're
the creator and you're the only creator that is able to raise
money because your community is really proud of the fact that
they've been able and have been successful in doing what they're
doing. I do believe that they picked up Son and I don't something
happened. I don't I've never spoken to Son privately about this,
but he did jump ship or got fired. I don't know what happened.
>> Um, but he wasn't part of PB anymore. >> I know
what happened. I just don't know if I'm supposed to talk about
it. So, >> I will give my assumptions.
>> I'm going to give my assumptions, which is Session,
really smart guy. Um,
and I think if you have someone who is smart, who's willing to
put their time and effort in, you shouldn't micromanage them,
and you also shouldn't take like
um accolades away from them. I feel like they probably put him
under somebody who should not be uh I don't know, like riding
him. I think that's the wrong word. Like he's nobody's pony to
ride, right? He is a show pony on his own. It's really weird
to just take somebody who is more of a social media presence
to put over him when he's probably really good decision maker
and thinker. >> Yeah. So I think he was he was under some
people
and Yeah, that's that's basically true is that like I think the
people who he was answering to he thought were not that smart,
not that good at whatever they were doing. Right. I think that
was >> Yes. and me working having um worked with Sagin
before I can't say I don't know anything that Sagin knows right
but I am like an eager helping hand so if I feel like there's
something that I can do um I think I have good resources I think
I have good work ethic I will [__] help as I can
and I do know Sagin is probably the type of person who doesn't
like watching people sit on their hands while he's doing all
the >> that was a big thing and I can I don't mind saying
okay that that was a huge thing. Okay, basically. Okay, I I'll
leak a little bit. I'll leak a little bit. Okay, >> leak
a little bit. I didn't learn this from SE. I learned this from
like a bunch of different places. Okay, but essentially I think
Brianna Woo was like leading part of this thing that was disjoint
from the canvasing and she kept stepping on Sjun's toes and trying
to dictate stuff for canvasing events and Sedona was basically
like can you off you lazy like you don't do anything. Get the
[__] out of here. In way nicer words. Okay, in way
nicer words. But it's basically like, "Hey, you got a whole bunch
of things on the go over there. Why don't you do some of your
own garbage, okay? And [__] off out of my like stop
trying to micromanage me when you don't do your own work." >> Was
like the general >> I don't know
>> I think this might help paint the picture for you guys.
Sin is Asian. >> That does help paint the picture. Yes.
>> Right. Like Senzhen is like Sen is the type of that
does your math homework for you for like a price and it seemed
like he was not getting paid enough to do these math homework.
You know what I >> Yeah. Here I'll help people. I'll paint
the picture. Sedge being Asian.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That Asian. >> Okay. We got
it. We got it. We figured it out. Yeah. So yeah, I think he basically
he would like actually do he would get his job done and then
other people are like reaching in to micromanage him that I think
he didn't appreciate
and I also think he was probably not the best and from what I
heard from other people maybe he wasn't always the best about
how he was handling that. >> So I think anyway >> like
you I didn't really hold it against uh Steven at the time for
not being like enthusiastic about fundraising because I really
wasn't sure what he is getting out of it. it seemed like they
were pushing for him to fund raise more than other creators or
for just like pushing it on their own. Um, it just it didn't
feel like a a mutually beneficial thing.
>> I from my point of view, but I could have been wrong.
I don't know. >> So, I had an argument with uh Brianna
Woo, I think on Reddit at some point. She was trying to defend
her like PE's contributions to like the Destiny community and
I was just like, "Seems like you guys don't give anything. You're
like asking there's no money that you guys put in." And her excuse
was we put in the voter file. So they bought like a federal or
national voter file and that includes like uh you know dem voters
that you could canvas with or that you could like addresses and
stuff. It's like email lists and whatever. They bought they bought
that like a national one. It was a lot of money. But then I found
out that you could just buy like city voter files for way cheaper
for the cities you're actually canvasing in. >> And so
it was like totally that was like a totally point that it didn't
have to cost them anywhere near that much money. They like they're
like, "Oh, we could save by buying this now." and canvas anywhere.
It's like, bro, >> that on top of the scrutiny of who they
were paying monthly, what they were paying them monthly, like
the idea that you need to fund raise.
Uh it it's just this and this is coming from a community who
is often told, "Oh, these leftists, they uh they will do fundraisers
for charity just for their reputation,
and they don't give a and who even knows how the money is allocated."
Obviously, you're you're begging this community to scrutinize
you. Uh yeah, and that they they did that and Woo didn't like
that. I think Woo eventually like dropped out though. Woo eventually
was like, "Yeah, no, I'm not doing that anymore." And if I'm
not mistaken, I think Erdite took her place eventually.
>> Oh, she took Woo's place. >> I think she basically
slotted in where Woo was if I'm not mistaken. I That's what I
recall hearing. I didn't write any of this down when I was being
told about it. So, so >> that must be why she
was able to cuz there was like a long time where she wasn't really
streaming. I think she said that she uh had the benefit of picking
up other work that she didn't have to stream anymore. >> I
think this is the primary reason that uh that we saw that really
horrible attempt at a studio was she was like working for PV.
So, I think I think basically she's supposed to be you know I
have I have a little sympathy for Destiny in this one aspect.
Okay. That he's like he's brought he's he's like convinced Erodite.
Okay. we can do. Erid's convincing we could do this content together.
Okay. Brings her down. She goes and joins PV and then you're
like supposed to be setting up the studio. You rent a different
apartment for it and she's just like not setting up the studio
ever.
I felt I feel a little empathy there. Okay. Yeah. >> I
feel a little empathy. A little >> That's like that's like
20 $30,000 in rent before you ever do your first
>> what's it even like to be that rich?
Uh, must be crazy. Must be crazy. >> I don't know. I live
in a house with a sleeping bag as a curtain.
>> That isn't even there anymore. It's literally not there.
I don't know what we're talking about. >> My favorite story
about, you know, >> such you fix things and then they just
hold it against you. Anyway, I literally fixed it. Okay. >> It's
so guy of you. Okay. Where are we at with this content?
Oh, I was just like kind of running through
>> we're talking about um we're maybe going to watch this.
I I think >> so here's here's we'll just talk through this
on stream a little bit. My concern is there's probably going
to be doc information here and doc information for people I get
along with, right? The people at PV. I'll try to skip through
it as best I can.
I don't think this this stuff is like kind of out there in a
way. I don't really want to rehlight it. So I'll try to I'll
try to get off of it when I can. But this was um Hutch wanted
Hutch has covered this stuff and and basically is upset about
like lies that happened here. Now the only thing I'll say, okay,
the only thing I'll say is when he says like he collaborated
with Destiny for canvasing events, he was not part of the pack.
It's like he didn't get money, >> but he was like everybody
who did get money was his dude, right? Like like and literally
everybody who got money was a Destiny guy. >> Like everybody
who was paid was like a Destiny guy. It it's like you could say
he's not getting money, but when you only hire his friends like
exclusively, which I I'll say they had people who weren't his
friends before that, but from that point forward, they like essentially
only hired his friends. From what I saw, Xander is a Destiny
guy. Xanderhal was on payroll before Destiny was a part of the
project, as was Bosch was a bunch of the progressive like far-lefty
people. >> Yeah, Xanderhal was there when I was first uh
when I first joined meetings, like
early 2023.
I'll never forget that meeting. The first meeting I joined, Genderhole
was like, "Yeah, so
you have anything to say to me? You want to apologize now?" Like,
I was going to apologize for that PayPal being his bank account.
Get out of here. Wrong, Jerry.
But But anyway, with Hutch, this is like this is frustrating
and also understandable because it's like, yeah, you're not saying
anything wrong here. >> Hold on. Hold on, hold on, hold
on. >> You are wrong. I'm sorry. Go ahead. >> You
What did Xanderhole want you to apologize for? Because he definitely
didn't confuse you for his editor. >> No, I did a He was
so mad because I did a whole video. Um I did like anything else.
I covered drama, right? So I have a stream going over it and
just laughing at him. >> Okay. Well, was it over the KEF
stuff where he had got in that big fight with Keflals or was
it something else? >> No, it was over PayPal being his
bank
>> Oh, and he was like getting scammed by his drug addict
girlfriend. Yeah, that was not a good look. >> Yes. And
then he goes on like >> he goes on Chud's stream. He's
like, "Yeah, I'll come back with the evidence." And he didn't
show up for like what is it? I think he hasn't been back on Chad's
stream since. >> He's collecting the evidence. Okay. >> We're
still waiting for the evidence.
Oh, that's so good.
>> Uh, good times. >> He was talking about cherry
today. Which cherry? Uh, Hunter Avalone has weighed in on Hassan's
coverage of PV. Hunter Avalone has weighed in. Wait, check DM.
Okay. Oh,
well, hold on. Yeah, so Porter Barrel I'll read Porter Beller's
message. Okay, I'll just read the whole thing. Okay, I figured
it out. This all went under the radar when it happened a week
ago. Then this actual 30 IQ
tweeted out and tagged every PV creator. Then Dan boosted it
to the moon. Basically announcing to all of Twitter that these
creators uh that all these creators full names and addresses
are available to find. Yeah, some of these people aren't very
smart. Okay. >> What are you reading? >> I'm reading
a direct message I got from Porter Beller. >> Oh, okay.
Okay. >> Yeah. In Discord. I'm not going to open up the
rest of those DMs. Okay. He's uh What did he say before that?
Yeah. I can't read those DMs. So, this person basically goes
and says like, "Oh, all all of these people have been doxed."
And then they tweet out all these things and it's like, "Okay,
you understand you're like redoxing them. You're just announcing
everybody how to find it, right? Hutch blasted and Dan boosted
it." No, no, no. Hutch is also not the best, but Hutch Hutch
is like complaining about it. It's the black cat person, the
the night kitten person. That person decided to announce to everybody
that they were uh they were
Yeah. Yeah.
Which realistically
I just very much hope that Pey, somebody from Pavey, let these
people know. Oh, but I know they didn't because I actually talked
to Dylan Burns about this like 4 months ago. And Dylan, no, no,
no, no, no. Dylan told me like four months ago in a private call
that he wasn't told that this just happened and they didn't even
let him know that they [__] this up. If I'm Oh, man.
I'm like I'm I'm 90% sure that's what he said. What did What
did Dylan Burns say about it today? Because I'm pretty sure Dylan
Burns was like kind of livid about this to be honest. I forget
why I have this picture of PV. Oh god. Please tell me this isn't
the New York the New York thing. Please tell me this isn't the
New York thing. Yeah, it's the New York thing. This is the New
York meetup. Jreg, we all remember this content, right? It's
crazy that this content is like from a year ago. Over a year
ago. This is over a year old. Jreg trolling PV. That's more than
a year ago.
PB for Zog. I came out to canvas to defeat Zog, dude. H crazy
stuff. Okay, I don't know how to cover this. I kind of want to
cover this, but I also know that like maybe I'll just I'll figure
out how to get around it. I'll I'll figure it out somehow. I'll
move around it a little bit. See here. I'm going to go back to
the Hutch tweet and then we'll we'll figure out how we're going
to cover this exactly. The Hunter tweet is censored at least.
Oh, did I pull up the Hunter Avalon tweet? I must have. I did
not. Where was this Hunter tweet? There it is. Hunter AA6.
Let's go. Hunter Avalone weighing in. Less than two years ago,
someone tried to murder me with a shotgun. Today, Hassan docks
me in front of over 30,000 live viewers. Really quite despicable
stuff. I always knew Hassan was a piece of [__] This
proves it. I mean, yeah.
>> Sure. Dude, do you not do you remember him
um almost getting shot, his girlfriend getting shot for him,
and then him coming back home and getting on like a debate panel?
>> You do you really think I use my girlfriend as a human
shield? Uh actually, if I use my girlfriend as a human shield,
why then would I have been videotaping things in this way? Why
Why if I use my girlfriend as a human shield, would I have done
this? It's like, do you really think that happened? That's a
little crazy. >> I just Why is he bringing up the shotgun?
That was such a That's a oneoff thing. His girlfriend had a partner
who put like um one of those Air Tags in her luggage or something.
Like it wasn't even because he it was like an obsessed fan for
Hunter. Like the dude whose girl he stole was after him. >> This
is so disingenuous. >> I also see a little misin chat from
Tequila Sunset. It says, "And then she went and did a six-man
gang bang." No, that was his ex-wife who went and did the six-man
orgy. Sorry, that that was entertaining this with >> Kingston.
She just entertained it. >> Yes, she just entertained a
lot of misin
>> I replied to Kingston Hawk the other day, by the way.
He wanted to say that Willy's Willy's piece wasn't that good.
I will agree. Willy's piece is, you know, I was grading it by
Willie. I'll agree that Ruben Ruben with a $3 donation. Give
me a second. >> $3. Wait, Hassan is bad. Asan is
bad. Although I do find it interesting. Apparently Destiny covered
this stuff on stream too is
I don't know what his complaint could be with this. Um that would
be interesting to me. I do think it's pretty bad. It looks like
Hassan went through and read all of the stuff off of Twitter.
That's kind of rough. Um
you see Will the Willy Mack passive aggression on Reddit. I did.
I don't >> what happened.
>> Oh, it's the Willy Mack Reddit comment. I uh I think
it's a little goofy. Let me pull this Willy Mack Reddit comment
for you guys. This guy is like so spineless. It's funny.
He's like in the Destiny subreddit and for some reason he posts,
"If Jtock is agreeing with me, maybe I really did all this up,
bro." >> Well, yeah, you [__] it up cuz he
just took all of your talking points and then made it into a
video like after you said >> I Yes, but also why would
he say this? Like why would you even do this as a meme? Like,
oh, maybe I did screw this all up. Why would you even say this
is a meme? Like, you how how does this guy operate with no agency?
Oh, maybe if JTO said this, maybe I maybe I actually am a Uh-huh.
getting cooked by DGG, bro. He's literally in the right. I if
he's going to let himself get mind and just like think he like
think he was wrong, he's literally in the right.
But it's fine. Did you see his comment section? Uh, I saw some
of his comment section. I saw some people calling for him to
be killed. Maybe that's what's happening is he's getting a little
scared of uh Destiny's newfound community. Okay, there's a couple
people who are like, "They didn't go far enough doxing you and
your wife's wedding." They didn't go far enough, actually. Like,
ah, you know what? Maybe this was not the community I want to
be on the wrong side of. Anyway, yeah, I did see that. Uh,
okay. So, we look at a little bit more of this. So, Hutch is
complaining about this. I was just I was looking through this
and I I some of this I didn't like and some of it I was like
totally on his side for. I do like the idea that um Destiny was
not a part of the pack. I understand he wasn't getting money
from the pack. He was totally the the pack wanted him way more
involved than he wanted to be. He just didn't want to think about
it, right? That's why he paid Son so that he didn't have to do
any work or put any thought into things. And I think the pack
wanted him way more involved. That's why they hired all of his
friends. And I don't think he gave a [__] None of
the work we had any had anything to do with Destiny. Um I mean
the fact that you were getting the work did, but it's fine. All
this stuff is completely made up out of dinner. All the Israel
stuff. Yeah, made out of thin air. It started getting spammed
over the weekend with unhinched replies accusing me of taking
Blood Bunny. Hundreds of lunatics posting a pic of an FC filing
of a single payment and claiming it is evidence that I was doing
Israeli propaganda. Guess we know where that came from. Uh yeah,
that's these people are uh it's all for some reason Tequila Sunset
whenever people see. So I can tell you exactly what it was. All
of these creators did politics downstream of Destiny and Destiny
was making like his pro-Israeli like champion of Israel stance
like trickle down to all the people who copy his takes on everything,
right? So, they all started copying the takes and everybody's
like, "Oh, that that's because of money." No, it's because of
like they just copy those talking points. That's like almost
certainly that's what it is, right? It's it's honestly not the
money. I promise you it's not the money. It is the the like influence,
right? Woo is a big Israel shield, too. Woo was not anywhere
near as big an Israel shill as she became at the time of PV.
She became a huge Israel shill, but she was not when she was
like or at least I didn't see her doing it when she was running
PV. She was out of PV, I want to say in December of 2023,
January of 2023, somewhere in there, she was out of PV. So, she
actually she put together a bunch of the people in PV and then
she was out.
So, people think that she was like really involved and but she
she wasn't. She was out in like December, January of 2023, somewhere
in there. >> I heard she literally flew to Israel so she
could go into Gaza >> and drink the adrenochrome from the
Palestinian children like through the straw fresh. >> Yeah,
I'm sure that's true. >> I can't cooperate that. It's just
a >> Sounds accurate. Sounds accurate. Who keeps doing
all this facial? Okay. I don't know. I That's a That's a rumor
started here. That is a classic Jtock talking point right there.
Lucas Jason Ted that she is the golem. She is the golem. That's
why she goes to Israel for upgrades. You know, gets a few new
instructions written in the scroll and they put it back in her
mouth. They close close it up. Okay. Okay. All right.
I don't know why we we like sway back and forth between real
analysis and just wild anti-semitism. Okay. It's >> it's
so hard to be look at Okay, look at the people that we're surrounded
by. It's so hard to be serious. These are the people that we
have to talk about.
>> That's not false. It's not false. I love I love that
this guy comes in and he's like, "Two days ago, huh?" Like six
days ago, he saw dox all these people. Two days ago, huh? Two
days ago. Yeah. It's like sometimes you can point out inaccuracies
if somebody's like embellishing or something. But like is it
really a big deal the difference between two days and six days?
Like that's not really inaccurate. It's like a couple days ago,
right? >> That is pure debate for Richard.
two days ago. Huh?
>> I just caught you in a lie.
>> You just made that up. You just made that up. I started
getting spammed over the weekend. Oh, yeah. Yeah. On top of him
maliciously, knowingly lying about PV, there's a partial docs
of several creators in the video he is reacting to. Just plastered
on his screen as he lobbs these insane accusations. Is this actually
allowed on at Twitch and at Twitch support? If so, how?
Side note. So, I'm gonna tell you, Hutch, the unfortunate thing
is is I'm guessing that doxing will require some maliciousness.
And if he's reading a public FC filing, which was where the incompetent
the PV put your information, that's probably not something that
they're going to ban him for, unfortunately. Uh they should they
should they should take that into account and I think they should
pro uh protect people's identities and I think there should be
some concern there. But hey, that's my personal thoughts. All
right. Han would have no reason to believe this information was
intended to be private. Why would he assume public FC filings
contain docf info? Uh because most public filings, most government
public filings, especially financial disclosures, contain DOCS
info. And if you are, you would just assume that and be like,
"Oh, I should be careful here." But yeah, like when I got the
uh what was it the
uh the Omidar Group's financial disclosures or whatever? or no,
no, 1630 financial disclosures. I was like, "Fuck, let me let
me check this real quick to make sure there's no docs info here.
No full addresses. Okay, we're good, right?" But Hassan is kind
of a So, it's true. I I also love that they're like, "Okay, also
Pavey ran for Jamal Bowman." It's like, "That was a different
part of PV. That was not your circle of PV." And you know that.
You know that, Hutch. You know it was not your part of PV that
did the the Jamal Bowman. Come on, man. Come on, man. So, the
doc is their real names, not their addresses. I thought it was
some of their addresses or something. But okay, on that in any
case, let's do this one first and we could take a look at the
bad empanada breakup just shortly after this. We did not check
the Reddit today, Salvation, but we will check the Reddit tomorrow.
Okay, promise. Promise I'll check the Reddit tomorrow. All right,
I think I've gone through this enough. I will try to be a little
bit more careful when we get to the Hassan stuff. Creger said
I should get I should run this clip by you real quick. He said
you would like this clip. I don't know what he means. Okay. >> Okay.
Snake can nut. He nuts in Ott all the time. Otacon. It's time
for your daily dose of nut. >> Yeah, Kger is just a weirdo
and he's like, Kger, just come on, man.
>> I come on, man.
>> homoerotic ASMR for Cherry.
>> The thing that I like about Hassan is that he's not
like a degenerate. He's a really standup guy. respectable
dresses, sharp except for that one Spongebob looking at shirt
and the bell bottom pants and he's really smart and he paved
his own way. >> Yeah, I don't know about that. >> The
way that like slop tubers
>> Okay. Uh well, maybe he did pave it on his own. Okay,
>> This is him. He's going to switch over to this bad empanada
video. Okay,
I don't want to watch this full bad empanada video. We're not
going to watch it. We'll watch it through Hassan and I'll try
to skip through whatever is there for docs info if it's there.
Okay. >> Yeah, this is a different version of >> Something
that I >> So, hold on. We pull back or some to actually
pay attention to this stuff. But like they used to make a mountain
out of a molehill with like any kind of DNC payubs that like
Harry Sisson got. So, this is like this is the big monty. This
just basically shows exactly where we're at. Slop tubers also
impacted.
Yeah, this is a different version of that. that I have always
found very >> Zionist slop tubers are all paid. So this
is about PV seven days ago >> Interesting is the way that
like slop
>> This is about prog. >> This is also I don't know
why he's calling them slop tubers when it's like they're aside
from Hutch. I think they were all political content creators
basically the entire time they've been doing content, right?
Sloptubers to me means like YouTubers, like drama YouTubers,
but maybe slop tubers just coming to encompass all of like political
commentary as well. I don't >> Well, a lot of politics
is drama. So, I assume Hassan thinks that if you don't cover
any of the like if you don't go in depth about any political
issue that you're just in politics for the drama >> Maybe
Hunter Avalone. Hunter Avalone's been doing politics for a long
ass time. Yeah. progressive victory
>> or progressive voice or something. I don't know. Progressive
victory >> Zionist so quickly and willingly even though
Zionist like propaganda really isn't that
creator because the appetite for it among the general public
has massively decreased and it's only getting worse for them.
So there's very little organic financial incentive as in like
people coming to watch your videos willingly and donating to
you like out of the you know just random people donating to you
rather than big donors like you know because they like your content.
So it I like I got linked this video for the first time today.
Okay, an ironic postus came in and he threw this video at me
and I'm like I'm not watching this without making sure there's
no doc info in it cuz that [__] And Hassan's like
okay here's the bad empanada video. I'm going to play it. I'm
going to walk away.
I'm going to go for a walk >> a bathroom or something.
I don't know. I do this. I don't really have a lot of heat for
this. As long as you're like listening, you come back, you comment.
But uh yeah, I saw Shondaanda Black comment. I'm glad I turned
down their invite to progressive victory. Shauna Black. It doesn't
really make sense. Most of the Zionist slop tubers have stagnated
or like seen their audiences drop as they have supported Israel
throughout the genocide. So, it doesn't really make much sense.
So, the question is where's the incentive? Right? Obviously,
these people don't believe the [__] that they spew
in most cases. They're just doing it because they feel a need,
like a primal need to defend Israel. This is bad and is crazy.
They're about to dox literally everyone in this sphere at that
time kind of. Yeah, I would. The thing is bad empanad knows what
he's putting in his video, right? I would say if Han just pulled
up like the documents and he was unsure, that's one thing. But
bad empanad is putting in his video and I think he's got a little
more intent. So, the question that I linger did this last
Yeah.
Okay. Am I crazy? Can somebody here tell me I could and maybe
I'm maybe I'm slandering. I thought Andre did a follow-up article
to his first Progressive Victory article where he posted a bunch
of this. Am I insane? I >> I thought he was the first one
to report on this and saying that he is not just um like telling
people publicly about it, but he is reporting PV to the FC,
>> He did report PV to the FC.
I think he has a response in his article, but I thought he did
an update to the to the article cuz in his article at the first
layer of his article, I believe he does not
dox anybody at the first layer. Okay. He might docs employees,
right, of PV, but I don't believe he does like addresses, but
he links to
he links to the FEC filings and has those addresses there. So,
I think he does a good job of like not doxing in the main article.
He edited out the part. Okay. But he did post it originally,
right, Kilo? Because I could have sworn on the primary article
he had like all the full information because I remember I was
going to read the article on stream and then he just literally
had all this doc's information in. I was like I'm not going to
read it. Okay. Yeah. I'm almost positive he did but now it's
like not there anymore. So crazy. All right. Regardless.
Okay. Regardless, I think that
I'm still going to be a little I'm going to try to be careful
here. Try to get around this stuff. >> Is there more to
it? And the answer >> I don't really believe in like the
spilled milk argument around docs information that like oh somebody
who's docsed once and now you can just put it anywhere. I think
that's pretty to be honest like there's a big difference between
somebody getting docs and then like normalizing just posting
all of their information everywhere. answer is yes. There is
more to it because at the very least we have a reasonable level
of evidence now that some of the Zionist slop tubers who we've
covered on this channel have been paid by Zionist
for quote unquote advertising services. And the only reason that
we know is is because of FEC filings where these sorts of payments
have to be disclosed. >> Hold on a second. Who is PV? PV
is Progressive Victory. It is a is it 501c3
Pat? 51c4. Oh, it's a carry committee. I knew this. It's a carry
committee. So, 501c4 mixed with an LLC and they um they can do
a lot of fundraising and they do, I believe, actual like advocacy
for candidates through this structure they have set up. I I read
the article before. I used to know more about it. I need to reread
it pretty quickly. Okay. They're a hybrid pack. Yeah, they're
a hybrid pack. So, Progressive Victory,
I was I was confused when I heard PV doc so much. So, what Progressive
Victory did was they used to have a setup where they didn't have
to disclose who they're paying and then they got kind of called
out for it, which I believe they got called out for it. It was
probably kind of illegal how they had it set up. They're probably
violating campaign finance laws. Okay. And they switched everybody
over or I was told accidentally listed everybody in their main
actual pack where they had to disclose things and they disclosed
every single creator's full names and addresses unfortunately.
Okay. through the FC filings which pretty [__] up.
I don't also don't think they told those creators when they did
it. So those creators information went out and they were not
told that that happened to them. Yes.
So now
it's Yeah, it's sure unintentional suicide docs. Yeah, sure.
They put published the PII of a bunch of their creators accidentally.
They didn't know about it. I mean, they filed the forms. I don't
think so. Tequila Sunset, but maybe I'm crazy. Okay, Rick Shelly.
Well, we'll see. We'll see. It's likely that behind the scenes
they're receiving even more money. So, all of this is publicly
available information from the FC website. You might know about
Progressive Victory. This is like um a political action committee
founded by like Destiny and Brianna Woo basically to like steal
money from people under >> Sam Dmala is getting totally
thrown under thrown out from under the bus. I guess Sam Dmala
just gets like uh no blame here. Just gets totally passed over.
We don't need to say this guy's name. I guess as I understand
they were submitting forms they weren't aware were getting uploaded
to the FCC website. I believe they changed it after they were
informed. Got it. >> As of them donating it to like the
Biden election campaign and in a 2-year period from 2023 to 2024
they distribute >> Hassan Hassan just hits play on this
video and is doing other the whole time. That's kind of insane.
It's kind of insane to just totally freeoot bad empanada's video
and then a week later be like, I'm kicking all bad empanada fans.
I hate this guy. I'm kicking him out of my community. Like, bro,
you just free a whole video from me. >> A handsome $1.2
million to themselves and people associated with them basically
for two things. To do Zionist propaganda and to kiss the ring
regarding like destiny and >> I don't I don't think it's
like I mean this is like bad empanada's like drama side um muddying
the waters a little bit. Oh, what the Oh, I thought Hassan was
like totally propagating these lies, like doubling down on these
lies. It sounds like he's about to say, "No, no, no. I don't
think this is what it was doing." Because Hassan would have gotten
the pitch, right? They wanted Hassan in progressive victory.
I'm guessing he got the pitch and understands that they were
doing organizing for like actual
>> Well, Hosan was going to come to the DC thing where
everyone was on a um talk with Roana. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah.
He didn't get clearance to go to the White House and I think
really nobody did but it was only mentioned that he didn't have
clearance and so he didn't come out but he was originally going
to be part of it. >> I think yeah uh Riy says um didn't
he up the Biden visit? I don't think it was just him. Um I think
Destiny I I think Destiny said that they probably all failed
their clearances. Like it was only Hassan that got >> Yeah,
because you have to think
>> it was
it was Hassan, it was Destiny, you got Vosch
who maybe has said suspect things about there being like
people in this country. >> It was like way before the terrorism
stuff or I guess it was after
way after. >> it's after the Hassan said Americans deserve
911. It's after Hassan says that they should have like militias
to
I think something about lawmakers basically imposing a genocide
on trans >> Okay, dude.
>> It's not confusing why these people didn't have clearance.
>> The brave soldier who can't crunch those eyeholes. Let's
go. Yeah, they all have their own hinge moments. I would say
if Assan failed, they probably all failed. I would guess. I if
I had to guess, you
>> it's not made about that. That is a function of it.
>> Yeah, it's cuz David Pacman's boring while also probably
more effective in mainstream politics. But listen, I need Can
we just get somewhat Is there really no way to have somebody
in the middle? Do we need like lollycons or consent violators
or
unhinged terrorist supporters? Or you can have somebody who's
like so boring you can your eyes water trying to focus on the
screen when they're on it like David Pacman. Are these the two
like polar opposites? This is the only political advocates we
can have. There's not a single person in the middle. >> But
when you get the person in the middle, they like they are so
motivated to stay in the middle. They don't even know how to
argue
uh abortion. They don't argue trans issues. They just defend
everything that they think the other side is um categorizing
as like the left's argument. Maybe I'm just talking about on
a personal level though. I'm not even talking about the politics.
I'm just saying like I don't mean like middle politically. I
just mean like can we just have somebody who like says to people
>> is pretty middle. Pac-Man is pretty middle middle. I
think he's like
uh very modern relationship style where he is in a monogous relationship.
He doesn't believe in the need for marriage or like a government
recognized marriage type of thing. That's pretty modern. was
pretty progressive. >> Yeah, I think that's just him being
cheap. I think that's him being worried about his life taking
his money. >> I got you to call it cheap. I won. That's
two and0. >> David Pacman's
>> Wait, what do you mean? How do you know he's you keeping
track of >> How did I know?
I've se I've seen he he
won't say there's a genocide in Where's Where's the genocide
happening? >> Uh Rwanda. He He won't say that there's
Let me look up Taylor Lorenza's tweet. I forgot my talking points.
>> Itria. I think there is actually a genocide somewhere
near Aritria, right? That know where Darur is? >> I don't
know. >> Yeah, Sudan. I thought it was between Sudan and
Itria. I thought that's where it was. Ethiopia. Darur is Sudan.
Okay. Okay, I got it. I got it. I got it. Jarpur is the fake.
I didn't say Jarpur. There's someone else saying jaw run or
some other troll. Captain Cappy pants. >> I'm not actually
looking up anything, so I hope you know to just keep going. >> Okay,
I'll hit >> for sure. But >> the way you pronounce
Itria. Well, I've never heard it before. The only The only way
I know itria is from the meme. Okay. But the racist guy who like
does clicks at the dude.
Race. Uh, advanced
racist. >> Is it pronounced Itra? I would like to see these
streamers pay attention to African conflicts.
>> Dude, Africa just won one today.
>> Got it. Got it. >> Kai Sanat finally donated to
Africa and proved it. >> Africa big. >> He proved
that racist slop tuber incorrect. Okay. In college, this drunken
frat bro started making clicking noises at me because I said
I was East African. I said, "You racist piece of I bet you have
no idea where I'm from." And with no hesitation, he said, "You're
probably from Eratraa." >> Oh, why are our heads so big?
>> Uh cuz we're covering bad empanadas do the Gotcha. Gotcha.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You know, we got to protect Got to protect
identities. >> Um I It's not just that, right? Like they
probably did cuz I I remember
>> they were doing like activations with like politicians
and [__] right? like like real politicians, not just
like specifically using it uh to to do uh Zionist propaganda.
Just shut up and listen to the vid, man. Okay, there is this
attitude. >> Oh, this is >> this is what always happens,
right? You're not quite extreme enough for the more extremist
people. That's some chatter. It just says just shut up and listen
to the video, man. >> He has evidence
>> Oh, no. >> It's not like I super Well, actually,
I do get along with some of the people. Actually, quite a few
of the people who are in PB. So like but I I dislike some of
the people in PV. I I'm like not incentivized to cover for them,
right? I don't think there's any Zionist element
like added to it at all. I would say again my in my opinion the
Zionist element that appears there is from people being downstream
of Destiny, being friends with Destiny and like kind of adopting
his talking points, watching him debate, watching his content,
people like adopting a pro-Zionist view, >> which hold
on cuz that really sucks. you brought up the Jamal Bowman thing
and I know that I've seen um progressive brat complain about
this on Twitter where she's like
I accepted this thing with progressive victory. I came out I
didn't even know that Destiny had anything to do with it. I trust
I trust Riverboat Jack. I came out for Riverboat Jack. I still
trust her. I just didn't know I was associated with an organization
that he's part of.
>> Yeah. But I mean, realistically, like again, there were
like multiple facets of PB. Like clearly somebody who was originally
running PV from like 2022
or something like because I think Vosch was trying to work with
PV for the 2022 midterms, wasn't he? I want to say that I remember
Vosch trying to do some for 2022 or maybe 2023 that like I think
it was progressive victory. Yeah. And I think somebody it must
have been further lefties who were working with it, right? Yeah,
I know Vosch was there well before Destiny. Yeah. So this was
like the leftovers of that were doing the New York canvasing
for for Jamal Bowman. So like yeah, I guess everybody gets painted
under the same brush for PV like as a as part of the Destiny
cohort. But they didn't even put those people together, right?
They intentionally split those people up and didn't mix those
audiences cuz those audience like each other >> kind of
they didn't intend to. I um
>> Right. There was like there were supposed to be two
different ones. I think it was supposed to be more of a competition.
like it was supposed to be like a friendly competition and I
think something didn't look like it was going to be a positive
turnout and they didn't end up right. There were supposed to
be two different ones happening at the same time and then something
fell through with the second one. >> Yeah. Well, I think
that was I think that was like Destiny's appearance didn't end
up going through or something >> because I think there
was one that's that was going to be in New York City and there
was going to be one that was going to be in Jersey. >> I
think that guy might have dropped out. The guy they were going
to canvas for. Yeah, something happened around him.
>> Uh, but either way, it wasn't that they were trying
to separate those groups. It w the whole point of PV was to put
people who don't get along under the same umbrella to be a coalition.
>> Yeah, I think that was the idea. I want to say that
they might have figured out that that wasn't working
or something. >> Seems like the people involved in it now,
which is bizarre. >> The PVX DG orbiter meetup was whack.
I don't know what you're talking about there. Full of hell. you
talking about? Yeah. What are you talking about? >> Uh,
no. There was like two different ones cuz I don't think that
he was there for the first one, but they still tried to go to
like the movies or something. Um, with the silly serious, right?
I think she tried to organize something, but you can only do
so much, right?
>> Effort was made. >> Efforts were made. All right.
Go going back to this. I just love that there's some bad empanada
fan. Just shut up and listen to the video, man. Let this smarter
guy talk. Okay. Let this bad empanada guy. Dude, I'd lose it.
Somebody said this [__] to me. You tell me to just
let the video play when it's my stream. It's like I will I will
ban you so hard I'll b you'll be gone. Not even not even a time
ban. Okay. Permanent ban. Do not come to my stream and tell me
to just play the video. You anyway. Like specifically using it
uh to to do uh Zionist propaganda. Just shut up and listen to
the vid man. Okay. There is this attitude that a lot of people
have that uh is very frustrating. I know more about this back
end than he does. Okay, so shut the [__] up. The
attitude that a lot of people have in this community about bad
empanada being like a prophetic figure when it comes to like
political discourse is >> okay. This is funny. Please keep
yapping and never play the video, sir. >> Actually starting
to annoy me and I'm sure it annoys him as well when people behave
in this like incredibly parasocial way. Please, I'm adding additional
information to what he is saying. Okay. >> I I just love
that I He's so brave. Okay. He's like saying I know more when
this guy's like chat box is on screen and the chat box live updates.
Like that guy can say anything right now. Right.
Put the reaction in the bag, little bro. Just put the reaction
in the bag, little bro. What are you doing? >> As someone
who more knowledgeable.
No, that's not it. They literally send money to their orbiters.
Yeah, but yeah. Okay. >> About the I know they sent money
to the orbiters, you [__] [__] I know
that already. I'm going to get to it. I'm saying that's only
one component. >> I'll also put it this I'll also say,
okay guys, well before they shut this down, I gave multiple calls
to action. Well, multiple pleas for action. I was like, Sandra
Ma, I can make arguments for your organization far better than
the you send to my stream. Okay, counter points is a [__]
Pay me money.
>> They're not doing a good job. Please, Sam Draola, give
me money. I will take money. I will shill, please. And he I He
never reached out. He never reached out.
>> Why would he reach out? We're over here talking like,
"Why are you paying people from Europe? Why are you paying a
Canadian? Why are you paying a
>> I'm a Canadian. I could do this. >> I never mocked
him for paying a Canadian cuz I was trying to get him to pay
a Canadian. Okay. That was that was somebody else. >> I
mocked the [__] out of him for that. >> Yeah.
Yeah, you did. Dumb ass. >> Okay. This is an organization
that I'm familiar with that I refused to work with for that reason.
Shut your stupid mouth up. Okay. I know more than bad empanada
on this and I know more than you on this, too. Please shut your
stupid mouth for one goddamn second before immediately going
the banana knows more than you. Like shut up. Jesus >> I
love when he's assertive like this. >> Oh my god. I can't
even talk about like a like a organization that >> uh I
need two seconds. I'll be right >> That is is tangentially
related to the the Taylor Loren article that we're talking about.
There's another pack that's like operating as a as a a pack within
the structure of the Democratic party that like does like some
camping events, some some other events like conducting interviews
with like politicians and [__] while also simultaneously
while also simultaneously they they were you know it was mostly
being used as a slush fund for Destiny's best friends.
>> Not criticizing him and not going after him for his
crimes and stuff like that. you go to the publicly available.
>> Yeah, this is one instance where bad empanad you were
completely align and chatters are still drama farming. It's mindboggling
to me. Like he's not even wrong. There's just some stuff that
he he's he's getting there's just some stuff that he's he's uh
not aware of. Okay.
See website you look up progressive victory pack. You go to dispersements
and you click on other dispersements. $1.3 million spent. So
>> not a funny not a funny joke. Not a funny joke. Not
a funny joke at all.
Um,
okay. Also, also can I point out something in Dan's tweet here?
Wait, which Dan tweet? >> Increase the amount of respect.
Did you go to dispersements
and you click on
>> what? Link the Dan tweet right now. Link the Dan tweet.
Oh, I was going to say the the idea of it being like a slush
fund for Destiny orbiters. Like I understand how that can be
thought of because so many people were on the payroll. Uh how
do I put this? Some people were not being paid as content creators
and I think basically anyone who wasn't being paid as a content
creator was doing a real job that required work, right? So I
don't know I don't know exactly what they show here precisely,
but there were people working like administrative roles. Those
people actually had to do work of a kind. Okay. >> Did
those people have qualifications?
>> Uh I mean I think some of them were essentially just
like
Okay. No. >> Okay, dude. >> No. Some of them were
probably fresh out of college, never had a job before. No.
>> Okay. But yeah, >> some of them probably got fired
from their last jobs. >> Did any of them really be doing
complicated things? Were they doing
>> They're doing pretty simple things to be >> It's
just it's just so fortunate for somebody to say, "Oh,
you know, Hassan just got like a leg up in the industry cuz he's
so lucky he knew somebody." How do you see a different association
from people getting like like legitimizing positions
in a political organization like this? >> Um, I mean, what
were they doing? Were they legitimizing positions? I don't know
if they're legit. >> No, I'm not I'm not saying it's not
the question of what were they doing? What did they get to put
on their resume? >> That they were like that they worked
for PB. I don't know. >> You're you're earning a pack.
I mean, you're earning you're earning money for doing really
um minuscule [__] and you get a padded resume. You
get your foot in the door in so many places. >> Uh maybe.
Sure.
I'm guessing that most people know that when you work in like
political stuff that you might not actually be doing any work.
I'm guessing cuz like I've seen Brianna Woo's resume and that
[__] is very misleading. >> Stop. Her hers
is a joke. Okay. She's literally on video saying that she's a
cyber security specialist. She's a cyber security expert for
people in Congress. She goes in and I can't I can't She's the
most unserious person. Her resume says Gamergate. I'm pretty
sure I heard >> her resume says all kinds of it says she's
like a tech expert and she's like a tech expert who consults
on tech legislation. It's like for the love of God, please don't
pretend that. >> Please stop. No, I think it's specifically
cyber security. Don't we watch that video, right? And then through
those messages, we saw somebody called her the like her insult
at Lav was something that somebody said to her like 10 years
ago or something. You're the
911 of >> the 911 of feminism. Yeah. >> You were
so disappointed. >> No, no, no, no. It's not just something
that that was said to her. It was said to her by by an account
that is widely expected to be her. Yes. That is widely expected
to be her doing a false flag like harassment of campaign against
>> man. You're just recycling your own
>> Yes, dude. Brianna was the [__] worst. Okay.
All right. I'll pull once we get to some part of this. There's
a Dan tweet and Yako's got some points on it that I'm going to
make on stream as well. Okay. We're going to we're going to have
to stop and talk about Mr. Saltman because Mr. Saltman's doing
some
>> $1.3 million.
>> So, you increase the amount of results per page and
um search the page for advertising services. And some of the
biggest payments on here, because most of these payments are
like $500 paid to canvases, canvases and stuff, some of the biggest
payments on here went to like people in Destiny's orbit for god
knows what. These are like relatively small streamers who clearly
have no real pool and paying them for advertising services is
insane given that they have no pool. What What's >> Yeah,
it's like Hunter Avalon. There's like a lot of a lot of orbiters.
Uh there's a dude who is literally Destiny's chef.
>> but hold on. I'm pretty confident the dude who's Destiny's
chef. Okay, I'm pretty confident that guy was not getting paid
to be like a an advertiser
if I'm not mistaken. Okay, I'm pretty sure
No, I can see >> I can see Counterpoints on here and Hunter
Avalon getting paid for digital advertising. I don't think Lykan
was in those meetings. I think Lykan was doing like uh like literally
Lykan was just like helping like Lyan would like go set up like
Lykan was around and Lykan helped with stuff. It was like, "Hey,
we need somebody who can come and help us like set up chairs."
I yeah, like I'm not I'm not trying to talk down Lyan, but I
think it was stuff like that. It's like literally we need bodies
who can like hold on do like security and and literally just
help us set up. He's working for free because he's friend. He
was not working for free as far as I >> They never even
made you do any content regarding politics for them even from
those meetings because I remember
um I was pregnant at the time and so I wasn't streaming on Twitch
and I didn't like half of the [__] that they were
saying. So, I wasn't going to post about that their ideas either.
And that was completely fine to Briana. She's like, I just want
you sit on the sit in on these meetings. And it's like I think
Lyken could be part of it and literally have no requirements
as far if it's anything similar to what like I was presented
or >> I don't think so. But that does sound much worse
what you're describing. So, Jesus, which I think is basically
what a bunch of other people were getting offered. So, I just
didn't think Leica was in that same role. We'll see if that flashes
by. I don't know. Can maybe clear up some misinfo as it happens.
I think I think he was in a different role than a lot of these
other people, but he used to sometimes appear on his uh on his
videos named Lyken, who is just his chef apparently, and he gets
paid there as well. And it's just like there is no What is this?
Uh wait, they paid out creators directly through the pack. Are
they stupid? I think so. That's that's >> Yeah, I think
so. It's a really bad It's not even a banger. It's a bad song,
but she do got a head like Stewie Griffin. >> You're going
to be smaller and in the corner or something. Yeah. Okay. I need
a big head to block all this. Okay. >> Like this is this
is what happened. This is what took place. Okay. And the pack
actually did uh unironically
uh raise a bunch of money off of like people who thought that
they were uh giving money to to a a um a political action committee
that was going to go around and and why is doxing so normalized
now? Um okay,
it is it is what is it? Um how should I put this? The information
being shown is
uh it's like pretty annoying if these people's names aren't out
there, right? >> People want to hurt each other as close
to the line as they possibly can without crossing the line. >> Well,
the issue with a lot of this stuff is it's filed publicly, right?
It's public. So, it's like literally in a public interest to
be put to be like put out there. There like some arguments for
this. Okay. Now, just because it's public doesn't mean you can
show it. And when Bad Empanada puts it all together, I guarantee
you that is for the purpose of harassment. I do think this probably
accurate to call what Bad Empanada is doing. Um, now it is doxing
name,
city, state, and zip code. It is not addresses, which is a little
slightly like a slight save from the worst thing, right? Um,
it's still like too much in my opinion. Pretty easily too much.
I wish Hassan had more discernment here and wasn't just showing
this directly. Um, mostly because Hassan's got all the money
in the world. He could easily pay somebody to just like censor
the stuff for him, right? >> You do knocking campus operations,
which they did. >> It's not the new norm though. It's not
the new norm. Full of hell. It's not the new norm. >> But
then also turned around. >> Every saying it's the new norm
is a Okay, just that this doesn't have to be the new norm. You
don't have to accept this is the new norm. It's not the new norm.
Literally, just don't do it. Just have your own actual like brain
process, right? It's not. But >> it requires people to
like um like socially we need to like shame people for doing
it. >> Yes. Uh it's not been normalized. In fact, it's
the most degenerate, disgusting shells of human beings that we
know that do this kind of thing. It's not been normalized. We
all look at it and go, "That's really disgusting. That's not
a normalized behavior at all." But Dylan Burns went live today
and he he was doxed, which showed his name and city he is from.
Uh I mean, it's pretty bad. Yeah. Yeah. It's I don't I don't
like that. I don't like that it's showing this stuff here. I'm
sure he would much rather this wasn't out there. >> Uh
but also turned around and basically created this like >> uh
structure for a bunch of Destiny's
>> Dollars. That's more than his entire YouTube channel
makes in Nope. That's uh that's not the order that happened in
Darish. But thank you for showing up tonight. Have a good one,
buddy. I like the new content direction. It's pretty >> In
like two months, I guarantee you. So you you know you search
for advertising aside from Hunter Avalone,
someone who it makes no sense. >> Just stop the video.
I'm not I'm I'm definitely not worried about just their names
being said. As long as I'm not showing any address information,
I'm I'm quite fine with this. Like it's not that scary to me
that >> and giving them like >> it's not scary to
me that like names are getting said unfortunately at this >> Like
three grand or $1,000 or even $500 to just like >> go to
an event and sit there and talk about how great the Democratic
Party is. is just like a waste of funds unless it is actually
created to to you know just like pay out your friends. You go
around and you do fundraisers from all these people that are
like, "Oh yeah, I want the Democrats to win. I'm going to fundra
for it." Right? And then it start and then all that happens in
the process is that you you just end up paying a bunch of dudes
that are friends with like Briana Woo and Destiny. Did Hutch
have viewership pre-Israel shilling? Hutch has been a streamer
for like 10 years. Yes,
Hutch has literally been a full-time content creator for like
a decade. What do you mean? Did he have viewership before Israel
shilling? Shut up. In the business, we call these scam packs.
Usually, their main method is buying a text or email list and
just massing contribution act the grassroot donors with some
generic line like stop Donald Trump, etc. People definitely fall
for it and it also severely harms the wider fundraising ecosystem.
It actually really frustrates professionals who do this for genuine
good reasons. I don't know if this was
um I don't know if progressive voice or pro progressive uh uh
what the was it progressive victory sorry not progressive voice
progressive v victory was was set up uh with honest intention
from the start or uh and then it just like kind of uh turned
into this like idiotic thing.
Okay. It turned into this like slush fun for for the besties.
I I don't know why you guys are acting like um Hush can't complain
because he didn't complain about Ethan doxing people or what
Dan did. I I don't know what you're talking about.
Um Hutch not complaining about other people doxing doesn't mean
you can like try to post information about him. That's
just so you know. Um >> it's like a totally >> and
unfortunately
the way things work is that a lot of people maybe develop more
empathy for a situation when they become like the recipient of
that. Right. What is it? Idubbbz didn't get empathy until he
was 35 or something. It's a thing. >> It could be a thing.
Uh Hutch was one of the first three people to upload gaming commentary
back in like 2008. Damn. I had no idea, >> right? Of a
of a best or if it was or if it always was supposed to be this
way and then it got led astray. I don't >> I mean, Hutch
is like perfectly hatable for like dumb ideas. I don't hate him
for them, but I'm saying like if you if you just disliked him
for his politics, that's fine. Just like don't have to make things
up. You just say I don't like his political ideas. People get
like really people get like crazy for some reason. I don't know.
But I do know that they actively tried to work with me as well
on numerous occasions.
Uh and I didn't work with them for this reason cuz I was like
there's no way. Like I've seen some of the people that you guys
have worked with. I'm not interested because that's insane. Um,
it shows me at the very least that you guys are not making the
right decisions. You know what I mean? Like you're just not making
uh there's there's people within the leadership structure that
like are very clearly making idiotic
idiotic choices. Like even if I'm aligned ostensibly with the
goals that you're trying to push for here, it just doesn't >> into
doing um pro genocide propaganda for Israel received generous
$2,000 payment from this pack despite the fact that he gets >> Wait,
first of all, this is not the the article that Taylor Loren wrote
about. This is not the same group. This is a different pack.
This is just a different pack that I know more about because
uh I I noticed what was going on, what they were doing, and I
and I thought, you know, this is suspicious. It's >> like
20 viewers and no one watches him or cares about what he says
at all. Like this is someone who >> This is just like not
true. By the way, Hutch literally gets like crazy viewership.
Like I don't know why. Hold on. I'll I'll pull it right now.
Give me a second. Uh Sully Gnome, I think it's just Hutch on
uh it's just Hutch on Twitch, right? It's like his Twitch viewership
is already like okay. It's not amazing, but it's okay. All right.
His Twitch viewership has been declining because he started streaming
on YouTube.
And let me go playboard. Let me find his up on uh YouTube. I
always see him with like 5 to 7K live. That's just totally made
up. I do think he gets like 1.5K though on Twitch or sorry on
YouTube.
I don't know where you came up with that number. That's 5 to
7K. That I think that's like insanely far off. But let me see
here. Hutch aggressive liberalism. That's like a wildly faroff
number. A playboard is so annoying.
Okay, there we go. Live. Okay, so Hutch is getting pull this
over.
Okay, Hutch is getting, you know, average concurrence
uh average concurren average of like the past month 629 on YouTube.
So 629 and like 270. He's he's averaging almost 1,000 concurrents,
right? Like that's a big number. I I'm going to be honest with
you. That's a big number. Both Loner Box and Hutch had good views
before joining PV. Yeah. Yeah. I Yeah. About, you know, 500 to
I think I think Loerbox took off a lot, but Loader Box took off
a lot from collabing with Destiny and stuff, right? Like that's
that's how he was taking off. He he might have joined PB PV coincidentally,
but it was not like it's not the money that made him take off
or something. >> intentionally spreads narratives that
cannot be justified. In fact, >> I covered progressive
voice last progressive victory last year and didn't get much
covered. Brianna Wu set this up with Destiny with the express
purpose of getting him a higher profile within the DNC and push
progressive voices out. Yourself included. Am I thinking of a
different pack then? Because PV did reach out to me quite a bit.
I thought it was I thought they did. I think they they wanted
to warlit
by 4 foot five Hassan right now. themselves
to the best of their ability within the Democratic Party. >> Greml
did >> infrastructure to make themselves look like they
got more emotion than they actually do. Unless I'm thinking of
a different pack.
I think it was PV though. I think it was progressive >> The
progenocide Zionist narrative and that are actively detrimental
to building a platform for yourself. So you have to wonder where's
the incentive coming from? Why does he do it? like he doesn't
make anywhere near enough money to do this [__] full
time, but he does it. He gets like 20. >> The other one
is >> What I do find funny though is that when when this
information first went live, okay, the first person who really
like published this stuff, from what I understand
was the all the names and everything was Old Man Lingre. Dan
is skitsoing out about Hassan right now on Twitter. Okay, Dan
is doing that. Old manre is the guy that Dan was in the server
with that they were both trying to dox Hassan's dad
and allegedly possibly some other people. Okay. I thought the
Hassan gun clip would be the worst he could do. Hassan is always
pushing himself to go further though. A true champion.
Right. Dan is like >> saying this is worse than that gun.
>> Yeah, he is. He is saying it's worse than the gun clip.
>> Would Would you say it's worse? I feel like this is
not worse.
It depends on how you look at it. There's a couple different
ways you could look at it to justify it, right? Like the people
who want to justify it will say, "Well, this is publicly filed
data with the FC." That's like, if you want a career in politics,
you probably should have your identity out there or something,
right? Some people will say that, which is whatever. I realize
I'm covering some stuff, but FC filings worse than the gun clip.
You see, some people say that. Other other people would say,
well, this intentionally like to harass some of these guys, which
makes it like worse, right? I'm not totally sure where I'm at,
but >> Okay. No, the gun clip. Okay. I'm I'm pro Hassan.
I'm not even sure why I'm pro Hassan, but I am. But the gun clip
is when he's posting the screenshot of how to hand make a gun
to kill them. Oh, what is the gun clip then?
>> The gun clip is I believe where he like tells somebody
to show up to his house, right? That's the clip. The gun the
gun like thing where that he did with regards to Tom Cotton was
was Yeah. posting that Shinszo AB Jerry Rick gun, >> but
it's a little different, I Oh, I don't know the gun clip. Then
>> he like pulled out an airsoft gun and was like, "Why
don't you show up to my house then, [__] See what
happens." Or something. Somebody was like telling saying they
wanted to hang him. If we find you, we're going to hang you.
He's like, "Show up to my Well, Dan's been so out about Hassan
for a long time." >> Oh, also, yeah, I forgot that. Uh,
so like the guy Dan associates with, the lingerie guy, is the
guy who originally posted all the PV doces.
And Dan doxes all of his enemies himself. Oh yeah, this guy's
was in the group chat with Dan, right, to try to doxan's dad.
>> Yes, it's against the toos.
Um, airsoft guns against toos maybe. I just don't know why we're
like moralizing it and pretending that this is like the worst
thing in the world. To is going to be way more flexible for massive
creators. Okay, it's why Kaisen almost hung a guy live on stream
and got no ban for it or got >> the magician.
The magician hung himself.
You worded that in such a way. >> Kaisen lynched a white
guy on stream to show that the blacks are winning the race war.
Okay. Kais's crazy. >> No, he uh there's a magician on
his stream that tried to do a magic trick and almost hung himself.
Okay. Wait, I remember Mau flashing his gun in VC. Mal did not
flash his gun. What are you talking about? He does the clicking
with the gun, but Mau doesn't go on camera. Why would he show
his gun? What is he talking about? That's some other dude. Some
other dude should have gone a VC >> Why is uh why is morale
scared to go on >> I don't know. >> Also, you're
the wrong person for me to say this to. >> Nobody. Yeah,
true.
>> Somebody sorted out over this when Charlie pulled out
the gun. Yeah, everybody watched the Charlie gun clip live on
stream. True. That's true. That's true. Guys, >> like the
grammar. >> Shouldn't everybody who watched Moist Critical
be banned technically because under the toss they're watching
something with a airsoft gun? It wasn't a real gun. It wasn't
a real gun and that's like provable. Elder baby goose. I forget
how it's provable exactly, but I believe it's like provable that
it's a what do you call it? Like an airsoft gun. Like it literally
doesn't have anything.
Your fat head is in the way. Yeah, it's going to stay in the
way cuz I'm eventually going to pull up that other thing and
I'm not going to risk like publishing a bunch of that [__]
or having screenshots of a bunch of that [__] Him
saying names or something is whatever. Talk swept so fast. What
am I sweeping for exactly? Plant dad, go ahead. It's your time
to shine. Plant dad, what am I sleeping for? What am I sweeping
for plant dad? Go.
>> Round not going on camera. True. I I think Mal just
doesn't go on camera. >> Let's see here. >> Going
to keep this big head up though. >> Ground game.
>> the other back that's doing the America tour, which
also is like again decided to go go with Destiny for some weird
reason. I don't know why. That has a litany of different complications.
But the National Ground Game Pack is the one that's funding the
America tour. No, it's the same. They reached out to me, too.
They got a few real leftists, but I think it was always Destiny
Align. Yeah. >> No, it was not. No, closer. I got no idea,
buddy. I don't know anything about Jimmy Door, but um this is
just incorrect. It was left as first. Progressive victory was
left as firsts. >> I thought you knew more. No, I'm confusing
different packs. I get reached out by like a bunch of different
packs, dummy, calm down. >> Why is this on doxing PV bad?
Because doxing is bad. Doxing is literally bad. >> How
are people not being sued for >> Because doxing is not
illegal. Plant dad, I don't know if you've ever heard anybody
talk about this ever.
I sorry I I don't want to be a Dxing is not technically illegal.
Read a take from JC. Uh yeah, we don't like doxing here, flat
earth. It's gay. If you're if you're such a made little that
you have to dox people on the internet because you lose internet
arguments and you're made then I don't know. I I don't really
have to say anything else. You're like a you're like totally
[__] made. You just get made fun of and you're like
I'm going to make you feel unsafe.
It's like a move. It's a It's a move or it's people who are like
seeking some sort of thrill, some sort of like power over others,
right? >> Isn't the pack owned by your uncle and was paying
Woo to run it? No, that's a I think that's a different one. That's
a Justice Democrats, I think. But in any
>> this is the structure is designed to shelter
uh to to hide the the nefarious activities chatters or rebellion
pack. Sorry, there's another one. That's the rebellion pack.
Justice Democrats is the early one. Wolfpack is another one that's
like specifically designed to to combat uh uh lobbying.
>> His uncle was involved in uh Justice Dems was involved
in Rebellion Pack with Briana Woo. Rebel Rebellion Pack is way
different than PB. It's not PB. It's not the same thing. Okay,
>> Wolfpack is different. Those are those are not like
uh those are not in the same vein here. Okay, Rebellion Pack
is the one that Brianna Woo was on. Um,
in any case, Progressive
the Progressive Victory Fund was, I believe, created by Brianna
Woo and Destiny and a couple other people. And they wanted to
they wanted to basically uh design it in a way where they could
get like, you know, Destiny and his orbiters and his supporters
a a more prominent place within the structure within the ecosystem
of the DNC within the ecos. I think there probably were some
long-term aspirations of building bridges with like uh Democratic
lawmakers and stuff. Absolutely. Right. That it was mostly about
prestige, mostly about gaining influence and networking for Destiny,
right? But but when when he joined, but there was a whole history
of progressive victory with Samala trying to reach out and do
the whole creator like influence thing before that. Okay. So,
I I do think it's like he's like kind of getting some things
correct. He's kind of not getting some things correct. Destiny
is very much like the Brian Tyler Cohen as as Brian Tyler Cohen
is the chorus. Destiny sort of became that for PV where it was
a lot of, you know, affiliated uh creators of him who who they
were
>> I don't think that's fair.
>> I don't think that's fair. No, because >> did
work. Yeah, I think Brian Tyler Cohen had an idea of like
an issue that he really wanted to
uh fix or that he thought he could help and he like created a
movement for it. Whereas uh Destiny did that and he was successful
for a bit, but then he his own I don't know fights on the internet
got in the way of that. Right. That's what happened in Nebraska
with that one person. Who was that guy? >> Art Gudgel.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And so progressive victory was someone
else finding a solution to his problem, I think. And uh that's
where I would differentiate them. >> Yeah. like for PE,
PEV like offered this idea that
um this umbrella company would make it so that these fights that
you have with other community members or other people in your
space because there's a coalition built with them like it won't
hinder your canvasing, right? >> Well, that was the thought.
But then, you know, every person they had participating also
had like it's like that could work if you had like 50 clean people
and like two unclean people. But when you have like when like
95% of the viewership comes from the people that would just get
complained about, I don't know that you get the protection
>> I don't know if that would have, you know, been effective
long term.
Overall, it's just a bit bizarre to take a lot of um you would
say controversial people and decide I'm going to protect you
from being scrutinized. >> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think
it was uh from Pavey's point of view, I think they were trying
their best to like I think they were trying to take advantage
of that, right? Oh, there's these big creators with these big
audiences. The downside for them is they usually like like if
they get attached to the candidate, it's bad. But I also think
like that this is where some conflicts arose because I think
Destiny wanted to meet the people. Destiny wanted to be involved.
He wanted his face on there. So it's like PV makes sense if you
want to sit and not be involved. Well, I mean that's why he went
met meant Roana, right? Like he wanted to get involved in some
of the DNC. >> Oh, yes. Yes. Yes. He Oh, I thought you
meant he wanted his face across like progressive victory. >> No,
no, no, no. I just mean like he he wanted to Yeah. He wanted
to get >> like involved. So So like ultimately I think
those goals conflict, right? you you want to use their audience,
>> but if you if they want like clout from it, then I don't
know. I don't that was the whole thing with PV. >> You
want to be the parasite. You don't want PV to be the parasite
on you, >> Well, it's not even like you have the audience.
You have like the audience and the backing and the money. Sorry,
you have like your audience could be monetized. You have an audience.
You have people who are willing to get engaged. Pave should bring
something to you to be able to use that. But what what it ended
up being was PV came and they're like, "Also, could you monetize
all of this? Also, could you like donate? Also, could you like
show for us on stream? And it's like, okay, I have like the audience.
I have like the infrastructure. I have like everything planned
here. What are you bringing? >> Do you think that's what
happens when they take uh creators who have baggage >> that
it might be harder to like uh fund >> High promise. It's
like high promises in the beginning, but then it's like down
the road. Uh well, you I can't really invite you to this because
you've got baggage kind of thing. I think I think it's Brianna
Woo just like uh selling like pipe dreams until something get
like happens, right? I feel like Brianna Woo Brianna Woo clearly
said we're going to have money for like these things. They felt
like multiple promises she made about funding fell through.
>> I know this for like a fact. Like she said we're going
to have this much money to do like these things and just never
ever ever happened. Like just nothing. So, and it basically like
came down to, okay, well, if Destiny's like funding all of it
off the back of his audience and like Sedon's going to be running
the house, do we need PV for? Like what what is what was PV's
purpose here? Um, that was just regards with regards to the canvasing.
Obviously, Pave was doing the like paying the influencers to
do their whatever. Who knows how much any of that helped or worked.
Was it a funding issue itself or was it just mismanaged?
I don't know because I can't say for sure. It might have just
been mismanaged. But I do know that the money for the houses
to like set the houses up and have people do what they called
like deep canvasing as in you go and you create longer relationships
with people and like consistently show up to the same houses
and tell them like hey uh we're representing like this candidate
we want to tell you about these issues. I think they were trying
to do something like this right at six houses across the US and
I think they got one house and that house I believe was mostly
funded by Destiny's community. It was bizarre cuz when I went
out to the Wisconsin place, um the the
building or the it looked like a house that we were operating
out of, uh after we were done, they told people like you can
apply for a job here. Like I I know you guys are volunteering,
but we actually pay people $20 an hour to Canvas. It's like a
legitimate job and it's a like already got a lot of funding.
It seems like >> I think that was when they were trying
to get people for those houses, I So, >> no, no, no, no.
This was out. No, this was outside of Progressive Victory. They
were working with people who already had like an established
>> um I would have to go back and find my pamphlets from
that place, but yeah, this was outside of Progressive Victory.
That town already had uh their own movement or their own um things
situated where canvasing was like an hourly rate
>> I see. Interesting. Um yeah, so there's like uh I can't
even remember where we were in the video. I'm just talking through
this because like I uh I've been like talked to a lot of people
around this like the whole time it was running and now I feel
like we're far enough away from all of it and things are like
old enough that I can't just talk about like how I saw some of
the stuff going which is um which is nice. It's cool to put it
all out there. >> The Democratic party >> kind of
stupid ever getting involved. I don't know why I thought it was
like a serious thing that we were doing. >> I think it
like could have been unfortunately I just think like any serious
thing that involves Rihanna Woo is going to fail every single
time.
Like it's it's basically like there's literally just an automatic
like law of the universe that it's like Brianna Woo is involved.
Yeah, that shit's failing. Good luck. >> And Democrats
due to their incompetence, I think, uh not because they did their
due diligence, mind you, but due to their straightforward incompetence
and lack of interest in like independent media farming just didn't
do that. It it like clearly it didn't work right. Um, which in
this circumstance I guess kind of helped them
um because because this would have probably uh blown up in their
faces even harder. Yeah, PV had a shadow investor along with
beu. The origins of the funding aren't clear, but there's a reason
these losers are able to go around the country while having the
combined audience of one of your gaming streams. No offense,
gaming frogs rise up. Your FEC report just says you gave a couple
grand to Bernie in 2020. L Yes. I believe it also has a dollar
that was given to Kristen Kirstston Cinema. I don't even know.
or not Kirstson cinema, Kirstson Gillibrand. Um I don't know
why.
It must have been a meme on the stream. I don't remember. >> Where's
Where's the money coming from? Here's the answer. He's paid to
do it. This is someone who has um justified the genocide on the
basis that Palestinian birth rates are too high. He's justified
the bombing of hospitals and the children within them. Why does
he do it? This is the answer. And just to be clear here, I'm
not saying this is the only payment they're getting. They're
certainly getting more than this. It's just to the extent that
the payment could be laundered through official means. This is
like the way that you
Dude, this guy just lies so badly. It's crazy. Like I listen,
they're certainly getting paid way more on top of this. Okay,
I know for a fact this is just like the only official channel
we could see, but they're obviously being paid on top of this
as well. He's just clearly making up. I like I almost find it
it's like we're watching this and it's not even like to be honest
this is gonna sound really biased and you guys are gonna think
it makes me sound bad. I feel like Nick Fentes is like a hundred
times more factually accurate than bad empanada. Like bad empanada
I just I anytime I watch him he just lies about like everything
like all the time. Like he's just like a pathological liar. You're
calling it pathological lying because he's saying the listed
pay on their tax documents is like obviously a >> He's
saying that he knows they'd get paid outside of these channels.
Like there would be like some kind of like laundered money outside
of these channels that they get paid through as >> Okay.
I I don't like the use of the word laundered, but I think you
are supposed to report stuff like if you gift for gas money,
if you gift for housing, if you gift for meals,
those things are supposed to get reported. And I actually probably
would be I would be I would lean on the side of they're not reporting
that. >> Okay, I see what you're saying. Okay. And maybe
there is Hold on. Maybe there is like an argument for this. >> Saying
laundered makes people think of something else. Yeah, >> sure.
It's not laundered wasn't the word I was worried about. It's
um it's the implication that they're getting money through like
illegal means on top of what they're getting through PV. And
yeah, not a lot of this was reported. And yeah, I don't believe
they were paid through the 501c4 guys. I think they were paid
through the attached LLC,
right? Am I mistaken? I think it's the PV LLC that did the the
the actual payments out to them. So I think I think that's how
they were paid. And so that's not reported. That's not like listed
anywhere. Um
yeah, Kilo's got it. Uh,
Queen Bee, I expect you to be more on the money with this stuff.
Okay. Kilo's got it though. They're being paid through the LLC
and so that stuff's not being reported. So, they would have been
getting money outside of this. Yes, this is actually only the
one month of reporting they did through this. Sure.
Um, but like these are their monthly payments. I don't think
they were even I think almost every single one of them would
have like basically
by this point at least by the time these documents were coming
out, I think they had all disclosed that they were getting paid
monthly, right? like quite a few of them. I don't know if there's
anybody who didn't disclose this like well I know Hutch absolutely
disclosed that he's being paid monthly by PV or being paid by
PV to do stuff when he was you find it certainly they're getting
paid in other ways besides this you know there's no requirement
for those payments to be made public we don't these ones we only
know about cuz they have to be made public legally who else have
we got here >> oh well
you are >> I tried my best I tried my best I tried my best
>> they that is a real thing Xanderhal is a drug Trump
will call the fat I'm sorry. I tried I tried to protect you,
Xanderhal. I tried I tried to protect you. Turns out everybody,
even the progressives hate Xanderhal. That's up. Okay. Why do
these guys on Xanderhal? I thought Xanderhal was on their side.
Xanderhal's name is from Xanderhal.
>> Xanderhal is the type of to tell his audience. Help
me save democracy by liking this video, posting a comment below,
and subscribe to the channel. And make sure you ding the bell
so you get a reminder the next
I I can't stand him. I don't even know why. I think it's irrational
at this >> Yeah, cuz you just said something that every
single YouTuber says. >> No, but they don't say to save
democracy. He's the type to say, "I need you to like this video."
To save
>> Damn. Sanderhal the politics slam peg is a wild sentence
to utter.
>> I'm going to cry the day that that happens with Pisco,
by the way. I'm actually going to cry if he ever says to save
democracy,
I need you to hit the bell to get a notification for my next
>> Guys, if you want to destroy democracy, I need you to
sub on kick to donate through Streamlabs or Kickbot to join the
Patreon. patreon.com/jok.
We are anti-democratic now, okay? We love Hassan. We're anti-democratic.
We're kind of like, >> we're we're grouch Marxist Leninists,
okay? We love art and want to uh overthrow everything. Okay.
>> Literally, Alex Jones, right now, the tear is coming
down my face. I probably need to go jump in a pool.
>> Okay. You're feeling traumatized. You've just been snaked
horribly. This guy is a demon. Oh my god. >> Ain't no Ain't
no way. Xylitol is an artificial sweetener that has laxative
effects. I know. I know what it is. I just like say that as a
joke. D has now moved to America. I like that he is uh his goal
is to to
the Hold on, let me move my head. There's no way Hassan's throwing
this one up. Okay, infamous snark tweeter.
Okay, he's got the Sadame tweet up on the screen. I got to move
this big.
There we go. No, not that. That one. Thank you. He actually >> Okay,
they don't even look They don't even look the same. Why does
this exist side by side? >> He's got it up. He's got it
up. I had to retweet this. Okay. It's just too funny. Listen,
snark. We're finding powerful connections via snarking. Okay.
>> are you having a full body shot >> within the
structure of the Democratic party? PSA leftists are not on our
team. They're just as bad as MAGA. If you're a person that takes
winning elections serious and then stop engaging with their content.
They think it's a game and it's not a game. Winning the midterms
is serious and needs to stay our central focus. Why are you promoting
a the teenagers? Our organization takes any allegation of this
nature extremely seriously. At the same time, we believe it's
important to uphold the principle that every individual is entitled
to due process. At this stage, no evidence has been presented
that substantiates these claims. Until and unless credible evidence
is brought forward, we will not be making decisions based on
solely unverified allegations. No, you don't understand. We need
this. We need this. Like he's he's brilliant. You know what's
really funny about this? Like if you if this person Destiny was
like unironically like a brilliant fundraiser, a brilliant marketer,
like truly a voice that was making an impact in this space with
the exception of like I guess making an impact for some of the
most brainbroken liberals who just think he is like the holy
prophet. Okay, then it's up. But at least it's like cold and
calculated for like some kind of broader grand reason, right?
But he don't even have that either. It's just all li
>> Isn't Cherry the one that up Xanderhol's progressive
victory payments or is that the other cherry? >> No, wrong
Cherry.
I I can't even pretend like I'm that other Cherry cuz that other
cherry was also in those calls. >> She was also paid by
Progressive Victory. You know is [__] up when your
babysitter also gets paid by the same by the pack. >> I
was like, "Wait, what? What babysitter?" And I was like, "It's
Xanderhole's babysitter. That's who it is." Uh
>> do they split? >> Like Xander's so useless his
babysitter also gets a check.
>> Dude, those DMs are hilarious, dude. Do you think Do
you think Xander Xanderhog got paid insane amounts of money,
too? I think Xanderhog got paid like three or four grand a month,
didn't he? Xanderhog got paid so much by that pack. No, I've
not seen that, Kilo. I've not seen. And that dude,
that was like the the susest thing about that when the first
meeting is with Xanderhol and his editor babysitter. Then it's
just like, what am I doing here? >> Tequila Sunset. I'm
sure that if Josiah was doing that for cheap, it was just cuz
he was like he was doing a favor to people. Josiah just likes
being Josiah just likes um networking. He's just a good guy.
Just likes networking. He's probably Oh, you're going to pay
me? Um yeah, I guess. I think Josiah also did a really good job
of disclosing, didn't he? Didn't he like actually say that he
was uh
feel like his disclosures were like really obvious if I remember
correctly? Okay. What >> you guys make some wild up video.
Jesus. >> And that's what always takes me back to like
the the uh whether I will respect
>> a a uh political action committee or not. Uh whether
they're making good decisions or not. Listen, >> when I
see them just like >> there is nothing there >> doing
this, I'm like, okay, it's clear that you're not
>> you're not fully aware of of what works. If you're actively
working with a person who is just all liability with zero upsides
whatsoever,
then you're not a serious group. You know what I mean? You're
not you're just What is this? Xanderthal hates you because you
called this friend without verifying when you were reacting to
his video. I just say queen bee that like the amount Josiah like
sorry when you're taking money like that I think it's pretty
much proportional to your overall pay and whatever the overall
pay he gets. Okay, that's like a just a drop in the bucket he
was getting from PB. Okay, >> Zionist propaganda. No way.
It's
No way.
There's no way you're paying Xander for advertising services.
Holy [__] This is this makes it so obvious that this
is just like a grift for Destiny to get people on his side defending
him from the allegations and like spreading Zionist propaganda
because like again just like a outright lie here for bada. Zanderhal
was clearly being paid first before any of these people. All
of Destiny's favorites are on here. All the people who are mysteriously
quiet about >> Shawn the Black. Funny as Laura is that
she only ran to Destiny after racism allegations of her own cause
causing Dean Withers to drop out of the tour's top spot.
Bro, brother
yo, I got haters I didn't even know existed. I got haters that
I'm just like making jokes about. Progressive Victory supported
Zoron though. No, that's why I said like they're not they're
not singularly focused on the reason why they also try to work
with me is because they want to gain legitimacy. They want to
gain legitimacy. You can't just only be a slush fund for a a
you know debate pervert
uh with a questionable background. Then obviously everyone's
going to be like what the [__] are you doing? You
have to be a legitimate force in order to gain prominence within
the Democratic Party's infrastructure. It's >> We ever
find out what happened to Aerodit's Twitter. Uh I think it's
just fine and sitting there totally normally.
>> Guy Cohen was a pretty fly for a white guy actor. >> I
like I like that. That was basically how they initially identified
him. Okay. They just identified him as the pretty fly white guy.
>> That isn't cultural abbreviation or >> I don't
know why I skipped past that because Yeah. I don't I don't know
why I skipped past that because technically he put that all out
there himself that he's the that guy and that you can like look
up his IND
whatever
both of your top haters pay the people around them to be their
friends
>> and also loathe me which is crazy
like these kinds of relationships should be uh uh should be defined
by like ideological commitments
a true commitment to uh fighting for what you actually believe
is correct. It's so crazy that like there is this there is this
space now filled to the brim with people who are getting like
$500 here and there or $1,000 here and there who uh are are actively
working not to like bring more people from the right to the liberal
side even which is something I do as well for the record but
instead just like actively
yell
spend almost all of their time yelling about the more marginal
left flank of the Democratic Party. This is so psychotic. It's
expected though. >> I hate that they did this to Hassan.
>> Yeah. Notice all of them are the ones that are silent
on Gaza. Gaza is a great way to filter these pieces of [__]
I think I think that might have been one of the requirements
unironically. Okay. There are some real It was not. It was not.
I just Man, I really wish these guys would not do this all the
time. It just It's such an easy way to discredit them. They look
so goofy. It's not as bad. I'm I'm done with the bad empanada
video. He's just like >> I did not do a bunch of them.
Assad is bad. Assan is bad. Assan is bad. Assan is bad. Assad
is bad. Assan is bad. Asan is bad. >> You are bad. Assad
is bad. >> You are bad
>> for making this a sub thing. Not a sub thing. Whatever
points thing. >> I just did all of them. Yeah. >> I
just did it again. >> Making jokes about uh the people
that got paid obviously uh including Destiny's uh private chef.
This is the part here. donations to pay my friends pack. The
guy used to be like it's Destiny's personal chef. It's someone
who um like this is the guy who Destiny pays to cook him food
and he got paid $500 by Destiny's um I take your donations to
pay my friends pack. The guy used to be like a Starcraft gamer.
One of Destiny's friends went by the name Lyken and now he is
Lykan cooks who and his job is to cook for Destiny. And
>> this video he made the video a week ago. Lyan don't
Lyan don't cut for Destiny no more. The [__] Could
we brainstorm some new channel point rewards? Nah. Nah. He got
do now. Is he just professionally Aaron's boyfriend? >> I
think fiance andor husband but
>> not sure what. >> Oh, okay. Promotion.
>> I think he just works a normal job. I think he just
does normal work.
>> Normal work. Normal work. >> What's that? >> I
don't know. Do you want me to tell you what what I think his
occupation is? Actually, no. Lykan works. Lykan works at Yeah,
>> I was making a joke that I don't know what a job is.
Jeez. >> Oh, I see. >> Buy Destiny's pack for supposed
advertising when he has no platform of his own whatsoever that
could ever possibly warrant being paid for advertising. Yeah,
as I said, it's just the tip of the iceberg. I guarantee these
people are getting paid more. I don't know why they if Dude,
I'm almost positive
that I remember Lykan doing like actual work for them. Lykan's
XC job story is so dumb. I don't know if that's true at all to
be honest with you. I don't know. I don't know what's true there.
Dan got a lot of hate for Lykan for some reason. I don't know
why to be honest with you. Um >> I think Wait, I remember.
It's cuz Lyan wanted to talk sometimes. >> That is actually
exactly what it is.
>> he would get mad that Lyan talked and he would get when
Destiny didn't talk. >> I'll be honest.
You can't win when people just don't want to work with you, right?
Like when Dan when Dan would like get angry at Lyan, I feel like
sometimes Lyan was like kind of not hitting the notes, right?
Like sometimes he was awkward with like his cutins, >> but
you could work around that and laugh at him and like make it
and Dan would like shut it down. Dan would like straight up just
be like so annoyed with Lykan when he would cut in and say something.
It was like a little >> Yeah, but I'm going to do a call
back. I'm going to do this is an Alex Jones thing because Ley
has ever done it to me. But Lykan got that laugh that's going
to hang on you for like 3 years. He got that evil type of laugh
and you will look at him sideways like are you laughing at me?
Don't laugh at me and look like you're enjoying it that much.
I don't know if anyone's got a clip. I bet you Lykan laughed
at Dan like one too many times.
He just knew that Lykan had to go before they even started working
together. >> Does he have a Does he have like a like >> He
has like
>> Yeah. And then he drags that [__] out. You
could feel like the venom behind his
>> Damn. Damn.
Uh dude, I I think I don't know. Oh, right. It was like
Yeah, I can I can get it now.
>> Yeah, I can I can hear it now. >> Yeah,
recently. It >> I think I think it could have worked with
him on the podcast. I think he had like sometimes awkward timing,
but I think you could like literally make it funny. And also
Dan has awkward as timing sometimes. Like Dan can be so awkward
and I I don't know why he didn't lean into it with Lykan. Could
easily done it,
>> but he just didn't. Honestly, it seemed like it would
have been so good considering Dan likes to drink and Lean likes
to make drinks.
>> Yeah. You just I don't understand. >> Um Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, I feel like I Yeah. I feel like um >> You
don't have to go any deeper into it. It's fine. No, I actually
I actually know exactly what happened and I like asked myself
that question and I realized and then I was like
this behind the scenes to kiss the ring to spreads propaganda
because there's no incentive structure for them to do this even
remotely organic you know if you talk about like basic reality
that actually appeals to even normal people like you know that
the obvious fact that Israel commits genocide and stuff like
that you can organically gain followers from normal people you
can't really do that from Zionism anymore. At least not right
now given the obvious genocide the appetite for that sort of
content. Yeah, that's why a lot of slop tubers are also like
not actively farming the um Hassan talks too much about genocide
button like they were before cuz like that probably is true to
some extent that like as it becomes like like worse as the situation
worsens making fun of Hassan for like talking about the dead
kids it doesn't hit quite the same does it like when you see
the piles and piles of dead kids now it's like what are you just
making fun of these you trying to use these dead kids as a shield
it's Well, you see all the dead kids now. It was a little funny.
It's a little funny. Yeah, it's a doc blocking. >> There's
obviously different forces that motivate these people and one
of them is like organic audience development, right? They're
content creators first and foremost. They're mercenaries. They
don't give a [__] about politics. That's fine. But
like at least they have to have some semblance, some capacity
to read the room. And when they read the room and they see that
the room is yelling free Palestine, [__] Israel over
and over again at them, they don't they can't hit that as hard
as they once did because they did do that for the past 22 months.
They did that pretty aggressively,
right? Um and and even then they didn't want to do it by like
taking a an open stance. They did it by just like attacking
uh people like myself, people like Frogan, uh others who were
actually actively fundraising, actively criticizing Israel. They
just like attacked uh all of the pro Palestine content creators
they could from other like drama related irrelevant uh points
of slander in a way for them to basically position themselves
not as like super pro-Israel. Uh so cuz you know you always need
a little bit of plausible deniability and you need to maintain
this like quote unquote aolitical
uh attitude that you have over this issue. Um but while simultaneously
still doing it right simultaneously still uh attacking and posist
I'm going to say it. Okay, that's uh I'm not joking. That's a
Queenman talking point one to one. Like that just is okay. I
don't know if you recognize it cuz I've had this argument with
him like a hundred times, but this is like his problem with all
the Willy Mack and Mudahar like them doing this kind of content
like the anti-Han content when you have no political opinion
and you want to say that you don't know anything about politics
but you're criticizing Hassan ostensibly for his political opinion,
right? But you don't understand the issue and you won't like
talk about the issue. you have no real opinion on the issue.
Try to stay neutral while attacking him for his it's like >> yeah
anyway >> yourself against those who are uh pro Palestine.
So they don't really do that anymore. So there's something else
that needs to keep motivating them. And I guess like you know
being a part of Destiny's orbit uh for a crumb of additional
eyeballs that you might get from his very loyal fandom and his
very loyal community could be one of those uh
Yeah, Hassan absolutely deserves to be criticized sometimes,
but uh I don't know. It's just
sure he does deserve to be criticized sometimes. I think the
the consistent videos went a little past that at some point.
>> Uh another one is just like direct payments that you
can get from this like Destiny's Friend slush fund. Or maybe
not. I don't know. I I don't really have a problem with people
doing it, I guess. But it was just it would be it would be better
if those Excuse me. Sorry. I I think it would be better if those
videos like understood his perspective and could at least like
somewhat pretend to fain at getting it at all, but they don't
even faint at getting it at all. They just like they just straw
man. They they just like don't understand what his actual position
is. They're just like he's like a total terrorist like supporter.
He loves terrorism. He just wants America to be destroyed and
he loves terrorism. And it's like I I think you could even argue
that in effect that's what happens, but it's like not what his
mind state is. And so there's just no attempt to understand.
Kind of >> And that's that's basically it. But it is true
that there are a lot of people who do get
genuinely captivated by uh whatever like weird hypnosis that
that he has over a bunch of content creators. Briana Woo being
one of them. Like she unironically learned everything about Israel
Palestine after October 7. And initially she was like, "Oh, it
it does seem like oh this spitting suddenly, oh, you know, I
care about the Palestinian people as a whole. And then like slowly
but surely uh through being a destiny orbiter, she became read
my emails a prominent critic of Palestine and Palestinians and
a prominent uh prominent supporter of Israel. She went in the
reverse direction as uh the general public on this issue. >> She
actually did in like a hilarious way,
dude. her her like tweets from from Israel were crazy. Like she's
just in Jerusalem and she's like, "I just saw Palestinian kids
stone a dog to death." It's like, "Okay." Uh, okay. I >> But
not just her, her and uh, Erodite.
>> They went at the same time. They must have gone together,
right? I don't think we've ever gotten any clarification on that.
They had to have gone together. They were at the same place.
>> They were tweeting about getting in a bomb shelter at
the same time.
Ah, like, "Oh my god, I do." I love the Houthies now, guys. Are
the Houthies about to make all my problems go away? That's a
joke though. That's a joke. I'm just kidding. Okay.
>> I heard that the paid for Arerodite's uh breast augmentation
and that's why she shills for them. I think they're filled with
like the tears of Palestinian
>> Oh, okay.
>> Cuz they don't use saline.
>> No. Play the video.
Now, let's get back to the other pack that's doing something
similar as well, but a little bit more structured and not as
hyperfocused on like, I don't know, making sure that uh one content
creator is and all of his friends are are uh churning out uh
loyal slop. Okay. So yeah, as we covered uh Taylor Lorenz's uh
article here, uh I listen,
we don't like Arrodite, but uh mostly out of my mostly out of
like empathy for myself. I'm trying to dance on people's uh channels
getting terminated. Okay, it's not like I'm trying to defend
Ardite. It's just like I don't like I don't like
at all. Okay, I think it's cringe to >> You're never going
to stop me from making jokes or criticizing somebody.
Oh, I'm totally down with the jokes. Sorry, I was the jelly man.
Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah. Anybody soying out. Making a
joke is obviously not dancing on somebody's grave. I hope she
gets her YouTube back if she didn't do anything uh awful. >> Oh
yeah. Somebody was saying that like somebody was doing it in
chat. They were like kind of being like, "Why don't we go check
out Eerite's YouTube channel?" Oh wait. I'm like I don't >> I'm
not a fan. I don't think we were dancing.
We we if we were okay we were doing this before you know our
biases okay we've disclosed our biases before not huge erodedite
fans okay you know our biases all right and we're not going to
dance on her grave anymore sorry we're not going to uh mock her
any more than we did before all right promise how did her channel
get deleted uh YouTube when you violate their community guidelines
multiple times will terminate your channel and so her channel
was terminated now I don't understand how that's possible But
to be honest, her content seems, while offensive in many ways,
her content didn't seem to violate the terms of service to me.
So, I'm not totally sure how that happened.
>> They stopped the saline from the trucks getting to Gaza
to fill up her breast implants. That's crazy. Two legs.
>> Okay. Supporter plus tier. Okay. >> It's what
the streets are saying.
>> Jesus. said before I spped to the other one, Progressive
Victory Fund. Um, we're going back to Chorus now. Okay, they
are a part of the contract clause is that they are not allowed
to disclose who funds them. They are not allowed to disclose
that they are funded at all. So, let's continue. There are some
real great advantages to housing this program in a nonprofit,
Graham Wilson, a lawyer working with Chorus, said to creators
on a Zoom. >> Is that Is that all? I think that's it. I
was just going to do the progressive victory part because I thought
uh Yeah, I was just going to do the progressive victory part.
Free Verrain.
Uh, Verrain can sit out for at least another day before I go
to bat for him. I like Verra. I do. We can sit out like one more
day at least. Mostly cuz I just don't want to undercut my mods.
Okay. My mods feel like that should be a week. I get it. I get
why they think that. >> You can sit for a week. >> He
can sit for He can sit for a little bit. Okay. >> All we
doing is posting cat pics in the Discord. You good? >> Ken
the Jellyman says Sher can watch Queen and VODs to watch back
air content. Not like there's any commentary over it. There's
not that much dead air. Okay, come on, man. Are we Are we for
real? Hold on a second. I need to
me one second. I'm moving stuff around. Give me a second. There
we go. We're back. We're back in the position, the non docs protecting
position. Guys, we're back. All right. I think um from this one,
we could look at the bad empanada. I was going to look at the
bad empanada thing and then I think that's possibly it. So
was watching some today. >> No one cares. >> He's
watching like I guess this guy talk >> you have the right
window on stream.
>> I believe so. Hold on. Is the Discord not right? No,
the Discord's right. Okay. So this guy, former Army member. Okay.
I think I saw him wants to support him and I think some bad epidata
fans are not going to like that is is my understanding of this.
Okay. Graham Platner. Yes.
that you pretend to be remorseful as you sell out to lobbyists.
>> Better not say anything positive about planner or bad
is going to get very >> No one car. >> Better not
say anything positive about platiner or be is going to get be
is going to be very angry.
>> Hey Hassan, you better not give your political opinion
or else bad is going to be mad at you. Okay.
Oh my god. These people know how to drive a wedge. Okay. Hassan,
don't give your opinion on your platform or bad is going to be
very angry at you. >> Sell out to corporations and no one
>> Shut the [__] up. Even in Okay, don't even
joke about
>> from the working class to the ruling class in American
history.
Symbolic opposition
does not reopen hospitals. Weak condemnations
do not bring back Roie Way. >> You're really showing a
gosh that did five Iraq tours. Do you not give a about Arab lives
after all you've done? Yes, I don't. I don't. That's what it
is. That must be it. >> Perma banan. Hold on. >> You're
really showing a guy. Do you see how fast? Do you see how practiced
that permaban was right there? >> The five rock tour. Do
you not give a [__] about Arab lives after all you've
done? Yes. I don't I don't That's what it is. >> Oh, it
must be must have been an admin. I know the mod who perma banned
this guy cuz that is the only the unbanned button >> Must
be it.
>> Yeah, you got me. >> He mad. >> He mad.
>> Mau. A performative politics that enables the destruction
of our way of life is disqualifying
for the role of United States Senator. >> The bad of yours
are already here pretty mad. I don't know how you do this with
so many idiots. I've been doing this my whole [__]
career. Who gives a [__] >> Dude, his sound
levels are not good. Can he get his mic up over the sound of
the crowd or
>> [__] are we doing? >> This doesn't
mean Look, I'm I'm I'm looking at what he's saying. >> Better
than Susan Collins. I understand that many of us have been burned
before >> and deserves an alternative. >> There's
no reason to immediately [__] assume that this is
another Federman clone. It can be the case status quo that she
is. >> But I'm not going to immediately slap
>> I am running because it is time. >> Why would
Why would you think he's a Federman club >> for change?
>> This dude literally once tweeted about >> Because
I believe he just started running for Congress >> and in
a better >> Hold on. What was that? What was that message?
S only had one tweet about Palestine. Suit has only one single
tweet about Palestine. But hey, at least he said that it was
a genocide, which is more than Bernie has done. Okay, I guess
this must be a Bernie endorsed candidate. There's a Bernie logo
in the top right here. I don't know why it says >> Literally,
one single tweet about >> I believe he just started running
from
>> That guy doesn't kill Arabs. Okay, that guy like that
guy killed everybody. This guy's like a you work for Blackwater.
That guy's people in every every continent. Okay. >> And
I believe that a politics that is willing to sell anyone out
is a politics that will eventually >> Betterman said all
the right things and had a stroke and became Republican. No,
he didn't. He didn't become Republican. He had a stroke and then
magically he woke up and was like the biggest Zionist on planet
Earth. People will tell you that these two events are disjoint,
but I'm asking you to notice a pattern. >> bro. Bro, bro,
bro, I'm sorry. We can't We I'm >> That's a joke about
misad brain chips. Okay, that's just a joke. It's just a >> Not
I'm not doing this whole thing with like leftists who just uh
genuinely genuinely come in here and they go, "Look, man. I'm
mentally ill and you need to abide by my standards right >> Okay.
stand in the way. >> Oh, uhoh.
>> My standards like I'm the most mentally ill person you
have ever encountered. I am a truly repulsive individual to every
single person around me. Okay? To every single person around
me. It is
how much I make people
I I revile people. People are they they shudder in disgust. They
throw up when they're around me. And you have to be just like
me in your analysis.
>> Okay. My mental illness is my strongest suit. My mental
illness and my insanity is what makes me the greatest leftist
of all time. It is a weapon. Okay, get a [__] job.
Shut the [__] up. Calm down. Okay, I didn't say that
his five tours, even his five tours is not even the uh major
uh issue here, even though that is an issue. The actual issue
is the fact that he also worked with private contractors.
Okay, we'll see. We'll see. We'll see where it goes. on the o
on the opposite side, it's like seemingly there is a there is
a movement for more populist left-wing
candidates
that are running and I will always put a leftist act in a seat
if I can.
Okay, that's it. >> He's just looking He's looking for
the next comment. He's looking for another comment. He just had
his whole rant. He's looking for another comment to set him off
further to finally pull the trigger. Right. >> Mental illness
is not a moral wrong. What the man? Shut the [__]
up. You No, that's not what I'm
That's it.
>> Hold on. I got to watch that again. >> Mental
illness is not a moral wrong. What the >> Okay, this one
I think he does. >> Shut the >> That one he does
one week timeout. >> You know that's not what I'm talking
about. It's not instantly one week. >> But when you present
your own schizophrenic hallucinations as though it's like the
most morally consistent political position, it you know it it
sets a setback for us, for all of us. Shut up.
>> We are in the straight. >> One more. One more.
One more and it's over. Okay. One more and it's done. >> We
are today. >> You learned from the trans chatter situation.
No, I don't think he did. I do not think he did. >> Because
that is what has happened. But it has happened because we let
it. And the world that we live in today is not >> adhy
chat need to run. This person's been there a while. Okay. This
person's a survivor. Right. how it has to be. We can have a health
care system that is not a mechanism of extracting wealth out
of working Americans, but a guarantee for safety and health for
all.
>> Oh, come on. One more. One more. One more. We got one
more, don't we? Checking the phone. >> Major life events
like buying a home or getting a college education. >> I'm
getting federan vibes from this guy. can be points of joy and
pride and not relegation to a lifetime of debt. >> Could
that be it? I I know there's got to be one more. Okay. >> Our
tax. >> We not noticing the guy in the crowd bottom left.
This guy, the neck crating
>> Dollars to schools and hospitals in America, not bombs
to destroy them and >> Uhoh. This is it. I can tell this
is it, bro. I agree with you 99% of the time, but I think you
[__] up with Adelita. with Platner. I don't think
he'll become another Federman. Oh, okay. There's a different
No, it's a different [__] up. Not that one. It won't
be that one. He's literally I just love I love watching Hassan's
stream sometimes just to see how he like processes. He's so ready
to fight with any chatter who even brings up like one iota. He's
so ready. He's just looking. He's not even listening to this
guy anymore. He hasn't heard a word this guy said for the past
90 seconds. He's just looking for the chatter who's gonna make
his day. He said it. He said it to them. Okay. Make my day, punk.
And and he's just looking for the one. Most of his chat knows
not to tag him right now. They're keeping their heads down. And
if you're a real chatter, okay, if you're a real one, you know
this is your moment, right? It's all worth it. It's worth it.
You sub for like 8 months just for this moment. Just for this
moment where you get to make the right comment that just like
sets that guy off in just the right way, right? >> And
then he gets to be like, "What? What the [__] do
you do? You're you're sub for eight months." He always does that.
He always complains. How are you How are you in my chat for eight
months and then you just start saying this out of >> Yeah,
I honestly if I was even serious in that chat most of the time
I would I'd find it hard not to just like cook up some uh some
crazy [__] about bad empanada and how Hassan sold
himself out or something. Right.
Right. Like just >> that's Don't do that to Hassan. >> It's
it's good. Okay. That's I I stream now. I don't get a time I
don't get any time to be a chatter. The only person I ever do
this to maybe is Queman, but Quimman just knows like my name
so he doesn't freak. He doesn't he can't get fooled by it. Like
the only person or maybe No, I haven't done it to Dickers yet,
but maybe one day. Okay. Otherwise, I don't I don't watch enough
to be able to chat. >> Uh it was a good time. >> I
don't do this, but sometimes I send JC and Quan uh clips of each
other to try to make them fight. >> How successful has
that been? How successful has that been? >> It's getting
there.
>> Notice notice I didn't get that queen and raid tonight.
Kind of kind of seem I kind of thought it was just random, but
now I'm seeing a pattern >> and take back the wealth. >> I
told him we can't let you live after that moment >> that
has been stolen by corrupt politicians and the >> Oh, we
found one. Hold on. Every campaign ad speaks of the genocide.
I spoke to him in person. He spoke of it. I talked to the finance
director for an hour and we talked about it. They're goated at
Hassanabi
>> corporations that bought them. >> No, that guy
is not calling this government to usher in a golden age for unions
and workers, not double down on gig work and union busting for
the benefit of Wall Street and CEOs.
And we can have an economy and a government that works for the
99%
and not just for the 1%. >> Every campaign from the genocide,
I spoke to him in person. He spoke of it. I talked to the finance
director for an hour. He talked about it. They're goated. I met
him in person. He spoke on it at an event near where I live.
He speaks about how he realizes
>> women is watching common rider black. No time for a
raid. Damn. >> That people were he's a capitalist manager
of disabled. >> I suggested Cherry that we watch anime
sometimes and she basically says she'd rather end it. It's It
kind of sucks. >> I just dead ass. I asked him. I said,
"You have to tell me right now if you're a because why the [__]
are you trying to watch anime?" Trying to make me watch anime.
What the hell? Right now. Yes or no? Are you a >> No. No.
I'm not >> not [__] watching anime.
>> Looks out for the Naruto. >> Yeah. Why you like
Naruto? It doesn't even make any sense. for children and for
the elderly. >> Where we lift each other up. Whether we
are trying to start businesses or go to college or buying a home.
Where we empower workers to fight for fair pay and safe conditions
and where we reap the profits of our hard work.
>> My girl also refused to watch even Avatar the Last Airbender
because she says anime is creepy. I get you. Uh anime can be
creepy, dude. It can be. There's just something that's good.
Yeah, there's just something that's good, but unlucky. Got to
watch some slop like Demon Slayer. Dude, we went to the movie
theater. I was like, "Look, we could we could go watch the Demon
Slayer movie." And she literally was like, "No." Disgusting.
She saw the whole cardboard cutout for Demon Slayer, was like,
"No." >> In public? >> Absolutely not. >> Gross.
Yeah. [__] gross.
>> No. Anime is creepy because it's so much. It's just
it's breathing. You freaked out because you could hear Nick Fund
breathing through his nose in that one clip. Anime is like really
loud breathing and you could tell like the vibe of what's going
on based on like the type of breathing that they're >> It's
so creepy.
Like Yeah. No. No. Don't breathe like >> Dragon Ball. Jeez.
Um No. Okay. It's not just Dragon Ball.
>> Okay. Finisher. Finish your clip. >> Oh, I was
just going to say I actually have no idea if he continues to
freak out here. We might have seen like the we had the whole
speech. This might that might have actually been the end. I just
noticed that he was like literally rabid looking for another
chatter. So I assume this wasn't the end of the clip. >> He
lo That's
by the way. Yeah, that's his platform. >> Never mind. He
loves Iraqis, by the way.
>> If you notice, he's running on a platform of of wanting
to kill more Iraqi children. Have you guys noticed that? That's
what he keeps saying over and over again. >> Building power,
>> dude. I really You need to shut the up. I always say
this.
>> Some of y'all just need to shut the [__]
up. You're getting in your own way.
>> dude. I'm I'm sorry. I remember I used to watch a lot
of Hassan. I have like a six sense for what this guy's going
to do. Okay. I knew that. Like I knew nothing about this clip.
I just heard heard he fought with Bad and Pinata. I just knew
from the way he was like sk scoping out that chat that he was
nowhere close to done and he was like just looking for the next
person he was going to fight with. He just found another one.
Okay. He's like rabid right now thinking about somebody he can
just tear apart.
And this might be it. This might be where he actually rants and
says he's going to ban these people.
>> Dude, I really >> Oh, hold on. I I missed that
eye roll. Hold on. >> Notice he's running on a platform
of of wanting to more Iraqi children. Have you guys noticed that?
That's what he keeps saying over and over again.
>> See, I really You need to shut the up. I always say
this.
>> Some of y'all just need to shut the up. You're getting
in your own way. Okay. >> A 5day work week. >> If
you're anti for real, no, I'm being sarcastic. I'm making fun
of the in the >> Ancestors organized for it and fought
for it
>> for fun.
>> No, I'm being sarcastic. I'm making fun of the in the
chat. ancestors organized
>> keep this way. Keep this man away from any stroke rays
and car crash beams.
They're like inherently anti-semitic in his chat. Or maybe not.
Maybe that's I feel like they're saying the same thing like the
stroke made John Federman
and fought for it. >> How's that anti-semitic? Um because
the implication of a stroke ray that makes him Zionist
would obviously be implying somebody wanted to do that. And usually
when you're implying that someone's got special technology to
achieve like their political goals, that's usually one group.
Okay.
>> I feel like I've seen that TV show where it's like they
use sounds to cause a stroke in the president. >> it's
some TV show on Netflix.
>> I can't think of it. of what some might want you to
believe. Power exists for those who are willing to organize
and to take it. >> And power is for the people. That is
what I am asking you to do here today is to come out and join.
>> Does it me off that everyone is now applauding God genocide
talking points after saying you were wrong? Why would that ever
piss me off? >> I don't care about being right.
>> I want others to also see the truth. I will always celebrate
people changing their idiotic positions initially. >> Asking
you to vote for him. >> Not even for a brief second do
I feel burned or angry or resentful about that. >> I'm
asking you to show up to come out, go to events, knock doors,
do the hard work, do what is uncomfortable,
and that
>> Sorry, I'm I'm just reading the chats trying to look
for the next one. Okay. At Hassanabi, I'm so nervous to get behind
this guy because he's so white. But amplifying Gaza on this scale
is a huge W. So >> he's so white. Ah, that's real as [__]
>> From this troubling chapter of our
>> is not the way he does. Entryism. That is a dead end.
You're right.
Why is Graham Platner running for Senate instead of just sitting
around in my Twitch chat talking about how no how everyone is
actually bad and wrong?
>> I think we're banning all mentions of bad empanada uh
going forward. By the way, we're banning mods. We should ban
all mentions of bad empanada and we should purge the community
of of all the bad empanada
enjoyers.
>> Get them out. >> No, it's done. I I don't give
a [__] Okay, I don't care.
>> Go watch him then. Okay. He has a sound critique and
sound analysis. Go watch him, please. Why? Because he's his loyalists
are so unimaginably annoying. And it's it's really annoying.
Not even because it's like, oh, he's saying something truthful
and that's actually undermining, you know, my my liberal perspective
or anything. >> I'll be real. Okay, I'll be real with you
guys. Okay, son's acting with a he's acting very fatly right
now. Okay, he's Nicholas Dioro in this situation. Bad empanadas
a certain like small lad. Okay, I'm just telling you
I see I sense a parallel. Okay,
I sense a parallel. It's annoying because it reminds me of how
much of a failure I am and how much of a failure he is because
it shows me that people only listen to whatever like figure that
they have parasoially invested themselves into rather than you
know going on their own journey of learning and developing their
own opinions. It's just another version of of what the I get
mad about with respect to like people who love molesty. Obviously
with bad empanada we are aligned on the ultimate goals. I think
okay but it's so dumb and childish to to come in here and be
like wow I well he said this I don't care. He is an irrelevant
figure. He's even more irrelevant than I am. Okay. And I'm an
irrelevant figure in the grand scheme of things as well. You
guys have propped us up, myself and Bad Empanada and whoever
the you watch and listen to as though we are we are these like
uh these these beacons, these political revolutionaries or whatever.
Okay, it's not the case. It's not the case at all. We're cooked.
We have no semblance of organizing. We have no We have We have
nothing. We just don't have anything. We don't have anything
in this [__] country. >> Jesus Christ, this
guy's blackpilled as >> you can expect from a robust left
movement in this country is to marginally improve the the working
conditions the marginally improve the the living conditions of
the working class in this nation while also simultaneously urging
American foreign policy to change its trajectory so it gets out
of the way. Okay, that's it. >> What an insane
what an insane revolutionary this guy is, guys. The best hope
the best you can hope for from a leftist movement is to slightly
improve working conditions and stop having such interventionist
foreign policy. Wow. >> Do I do I have to be depressed
if I'm a Hassan fan? >> Uh no. Do you take his politics
>> I don't and I don't know.
Yeah, the answer is no. So if you don't, then no. You don't have
to be depressed. You can just laugh. >> Okay. If I if I
want to be part of a leftist movement, do I have to be depressed?
Um, I think like probably
in order to gain acceptance there. Yeah. But but like not literally.
>> You just learn to fake it. Maybe >> I don't think
you have to fake depression. I might just fit in. >> I
hate working. I hate my job. Just kidding. That's That's already
That's going to label you as a fake. Okay. I love not having
a job. There you go. >> No. No. It's I can't work.
I am
>> What was that one? I am disabled because I can't wake
up in the morning. And that was like a real Tik Tok, wasn't it?
>> Was it? I
miss I miss Tik Tok. [__] >> Oh, no. It was
wild. I have to find it. There was some [__] who's
on like disability. She can't work a job because she can't wake
up in the mornings. I was like, "Oh [__] me too."
Like, yeah, me
>> That is absurd. Uh, yeah. All right, guys. It looks
like that's it for Hassan. Hassan very mad at this guy. So, guess
what race she is? This person. Which person? Anyway, okay. I'm
uh we're >> She was white. She was white. Calm down, you
guys. >> Oh, that person. I would have guessed white. Okay,
I think we're uh we're ending the stream, guys. We're going to
bed. I'm very tired. Okay, where am I where am I hosting? Who's
online? I's online. and we'll rate IO. Okay, guys, go say hi
to Iiko. She's checking some stuff out. I will be back
tomorrow. We'll be back tomorrow. Have a good night, guys. Talk
to you later and we'll see y'all. Yeah, we'll see. >> Wait,
maybe maybe we'll be back
>> Maybe. Maybe. Okay, have a good night, guys. Bye.